it has now been nearly a month
since since the storming of the capital
in washington dc
and just the other night ocasio-cortez
told this story recount recounting this
this very
traumatic moment for her and i mean that
it was traumatic for her she says so
where a police officer knocked on her
door she says pounded very loudly
said where is she and she was afraid for
her life thinking it was the writers
well it was actually a cop who was there
to save her
and then ushered her and her staff out
and told him to run and go to another
building
it's created kind of a tabloid
controversy that i think is a dumb
distraction because right now we have
the gamestop rebellion we have joe biden
signing or
preparing an executive order to
nationalize nine million immigrants so
like we have a lot going on in this
country
but for some reason the headlines are
dominated by alexandria ocasio-cortez
and michael tracy it really is the
weirdest thing
and so here we are once again wrapped up
in this but you know what
we were sitting here talking about
shouldn't we open with like china
threatening taiwan and joe biden's
immigration policies and i was like
you're right you're right
but this is trending we should address
it in a critical way
to call it out and we're going to call
it out we're going to call out how
you know now that trump is gone what
we're seeing is
many of these tabloid drama culture war
outlets
are desperate to get something so
they're going after marjorie taylor
green now aoc comes out
michael tracy tweeted one thing and now
they're writing news stories in newsweek
about him
dude he's just a guy on twitter he's a
journalist what is this it's ridiculous
and then we're going to talk about china
and we're going to talk about
immigration and then we're going to talk
about life after death and just kind of
chill out you know and have some some
more serious conversations
i don't i don't really like talking
about people so we are going to be
talking about aoc and the drama
but we're talking about the ideas around
it and why it's happening so that being
said we are joined today by
none other than sheamus of freedom tunes
it's great to be back tim i've missed
this i've missed this
how long has it been it has been since
the election yeah yeah cause you were
like
pointing at a bunch of things we built
you're like what's happening yeah i know
i was here i was like what has happened
to this house
you guys have you don't even want to
know what's going on behind the scenes
here it's actually terrifying it's a lot
i wish i hadn't learned
my eyes have been open and i can't close
them now it's horrifying all right
i know it's interesting you said about
aoc and you said you don't like talking
about people
i also don't i like making cartoons
about them
and i feel that there's like a way to
make it good-natured and
to poke fun at them exactly the way you
want to but i find when you're on the
top
on the spot talking about these public
figures it's it's a little worrisome
because i don't want to say the wrong
thing and treat this person unjustly
even though i think they're wrong about
basically everything i want to rag
on people who are taking this
like whole situation seriously and it's
not about
aoc saying you know i was experiencing
trauma i can respect someone you know
not
like someone being scared and and their
perspective and when i heard her tell
the story i was like how about that
like you know all right and then i moved
on the issue is the drama that they've
developed around it
latching on to michael tracy and glenn
greenwald and trying to make this into a
big story because they don't
maybe it's because they know that
they'll get more traffic doing a
snapback article like woo then they then
actually talk about important things
so yeah you'll get into it well i'd be
interested to see the coverage on
aoc's story compared to the coverage on
ron paul being attacked
or rand paul being attacked oh right for
sure yeah well we got luke koski's
chilling well i actually talked about
the story today
in my own personal video and i just
mentioned it for five seconds saying
it's absolutely nonsensical stupid and
has no effect on your life
but here we are even the rolling stones
wrote an article titled alexandria
ocasio-cortez
said something genuine so of course men
reacted poorly that's on the rolling
stones right now of course
going after michael tracy and other
people the world has gone mad there's a
lot more important things that we should
be focusing on but you know
c'est la vie welcome back beautiful and
amazing human beings this is ubudowski
of we are change.org if you want to get
involved with what i'm doing you could
check me out and my efforts on we are
change.org forward slash donate and i
release videos almost
daily on the youtube channel we are
change thanks for having me
wow i should have done a plug like that
that was way better yeah yeah yeah i've
studied
uh hey everybody i'm ian crossland i
also i'm not a huge fan of talking about
people
but i'd like talking about uh sociology
and cult worship and you know what we're
looking at right now with like
youtube stars like ocs uh a celebrity
using the youtubes to get to get our
message out there
but i really like talking about what we
were talking about earlier like what's
god what is god exactly that's what
we're going to get to later on
yeah and what is god are you pro-death
penalty luke um
no well yeah we're having that
conversation also are you just putting
me on the spot
what's your stance on abortion ian are
you abortion or anti-abortion
that one goes for like 10 hours as soon
as it happens we had a debate about that
that was like an out
we took up like the last hour of the
show it was good though yeah
okay uh also soccer patch let's just i
am here in the corner pushing all the
buttons trying to keep up with all this
conversation thank you liz
that's the introduction let's let's jump
into the tabloid drama but before we do
head over to timcast.com become a member
we have this really great
members only a post from the other night
where uh we we showed this video from
tony robbins calling out covet as
hysteria saying
john hopkins did the study they said the
the death rate hasn't changed like it's
2.8 million
interesting conversation the best part
is somehow we managed to segue into a
story about luke getting catfished
and it's just talking about nonsense i
guess i have some very interesting
stories
and if you you can watch it if you go to
timcast.com and become a member
but uh let me i will stress i've been
i've been going really really hard on
the hedge funds and wall street and the
establishment elites
and this is the real issue the real
threat when the left and the right agree
one of the reasons i think that we're
getting this aoc story is as prominent
as it is
is because it easily distracts from the
wall street bets
you know gamestop rebellion so all of a
sudden everyone's writing stories they
tried to divert saying by silver
it didn't work now they're like hey
everybody look at this people are
fighting again
yeah so we run the risk of getting
banned
when we actually cut through the noise
and talk about real issues
and they've been banning a lot of people
so that's why we said teamcast.com and
we're expanding we're going to be doing
a um we have a new format coming out
soon
there's a new blog section and we're
going to be featuring content videos and
writing original stuff and putting up
original stuff it'll be a lot of fun
yeah
you were gonna you were gonna say
something james yeah i posted a cartoon
today about uh the whole wall street
fiasco if you guys want to check out
freedom tunes that's
freedom tunes and it's called uh game
stunks and i think you'll all love it
very much awesome
yeah also uh ethereum hit an all-time
high today what did it hit uh 1490 or
something wow
wow where's there where's the articles
about that tiny bit
yeah seriously yeah yeah uh bill when he
was here he said to buy some so i was
like okay
yeah it's that's that's a huge gain wow
i should i should look into that yeah
anyway let's talk news here's a story
from fox news aoc
questions if capitol police officer
tried to put her in a vulnerable
situation
quote he was looking at me with a
tremendous amount of anger and hostility
they say rep aoc wondered aloud monday
whether a capital police officer who
barged into her office to direct her to
a safe location during the january 6
riot was actually trying to protect her
or not
saying like so many other communities in
this country just that presence doesn't
give you a clear signal if you're safe
or not
so so the situation did not feel okay
aoc has four weeks said she thought she
was going to die that day
she said the officer had anger and
hostility in his eyes and she questioned
whether or not
he had been trying to put her in a
vulnerable situation still
she said she wasn't sure and was trying
not to pass judgment
the new york democrat detailed on
instagram live monday night the series
of events that led her to question the
officer's motives
at the time she realized riders had
breached the capitol and she hid in her
office fearing for her life
she says that uh a little after 1 pm she
heard banging on the door
like someone was trying to break down
the door fearing it was a rioter she hid
in her bathroom
she said she heard repeated yells of
where is she through the door hinge
i see this white man in a black beanie i
have never been quieter in my life
all of a sudden i hear my staffer gl out
hey it's okay come out
when i come out this man is a capital
police officer he was looking at me with
a tremendous amount of anger and
hostility
things weren't adding up she continued
she said her staffer had also not known
if the officer was there to help us or
hurt us
that is how aggressive the situation was
in that moment we couldn't tell if this
was a good situation or a bad situation
well i'll tell you the first thing i'll
say is
aoc has no conflict experience what did
she do she went to boston university or
whatever
she did work at a bar though i mean the
bar fights you break out i mean
but yeah you know she's she so i i can
respect that she was genuinely scared
100 percent
but i i am a little uh mildly perturbed
yeah at this story where you have a cop
rushing to
her because he knows she's famous i'm
assuming
but look this cop goes to her office
knocks on the door
probably loudly i mean there's a riot
going on and he says where is she
she assumes all these negative things
about the cop who actually saved her
and protected her and told her to go to
a different building yeah i don't so
what is the exact complaint
here from her just that he was too angry
or is harsh in his tone or did he say
something to her i don't understand yeah
he was harsh in his tone
and you know uh uh interestingly i'm i'm
not gonna put all the heat on aoc for
this one she was telling a story about
how she felt and how she perceived it
yeah i get it that's fine
the issue is how the media is latching
onto it to turn it into a culture war
issue that's a very good point and then
michael tracy called it emotional
manipulation i even said earlier
i would call it manipulation actually
you know michael tracy is right
but i don't think it's you know what she
did when she told the story was more
about promoting herself
and getting more attention because she
is a master at turning the story into a
story about aoc
now it's it's nearly a month later and
the capital riot story is
all about aoc and ted cruz almost had
her killed
and now she's hiding in her bathroom and
there are a lot of questions we got to
bring up about this story but i don't
look you look like you're gonna say i
mean it was an intense moment it would
be interesting to know if this was
before and after the police
shot and killed someone but you know
that officer probably thought he was
risking his life and it was a very
intense moment so i think that's worth
factoring in here too and as you said
what's what's the story here there's
none it's a nothing burger nothing
happened
it's a personal story that again the
mainstream media and alexandria
ocasio-cortez even though she's not
really
uh you know obsessing about it and
pushing it like the mainstream media is
she knows what she's doing on the same
hand as well she knows
the attention this is going to get this
is going to garner she knows the talking
points
and uh essentially i mean we're talking
about it right
right yeah exactly it's a perfect story
because it's going to get it's going to
get both sides worked up you're going to
have all the boomer cons you just love
uh picking over every single one of the
aoc's sentences and
and um freaking out about and granted
like their subject matter there but at
some point when you argue with a fool
there are two and you just have to
ignore some of this yeah this is so i'm
gonna tell you
what yeah i hear you on that too because
the media keeps shoving it in our face
i want to tell you exactly why i decided
to talk about the story because it's
precisely how much i don't care about it
and it embodies perfectly what i see
almost like every day in news this was
trending
this story was trending this morning the
young turks dedicated a live segment to
this like pathetic michael tracy and i'm
like that's
is that's what they are that's what they
do that's what these
these news outlets and even the young
turks do they
they pile on to the drama when i saw
that
aoc was you know this live stream you
know what i thought huh
that's it yeah uh-huh you know what i
thought a white guy in a black beanie
hmm i just pictured you i pictured you
spitting it was yeah
here's the point beautiful there are
stories like this all the time
where it's like i see someone you know
like someone from the squad tweet
something
and then i'm just like i just see it and
i go huh how is that impacting anything
she told the story
it was her feelings in in in the moment
she told it the way she felt it it was
good for her generated a lot of press
congratulations
and then when michael tracy criticizes
her and he's just some dude on twitter
i'm not trying to be disrespectful he's
a journalist he's got a twitter account
it turns into a major story where
everyone's picking it up
listen what we need to focus on and we
need a media to call out say
biden's 43 executive orders instead what
we get
is drama between twitter accounts
yeah yeah i get used to that though i
mean that gets views that's more
interesting who cares about executive
orders
and who in the media is going to talk
about them yep you know what i would
like to point out i think maybe congress
should have combat
training now maybe it's maybe it should
be important if you're going to run for
office and you get voted in that you
need some sort of military training you
remember when
when politicians used to duel each other
yes yeah i mean none of us remember it
we weren't there
but uh historically yes you read about
that in a history
book or two i was watching back to the
features on the other day and i was back
to feature three
where you know biff or whatever no no
that was his name buford that was his
name
he's gonna you know shoot at noon or
whatever old cliche
and i was like yeah it's kind of like we
used to be like
the these these high noon 10 pesos duels
in the wild west
like we used to do this all the time
yeah like politicians literally would
just shoot each other dude if you
if you ran into someone with your horse
they'd just shoot you
were they what do you remember about
you're playing too much red dawn
redemption
actually do you guys remember about 10
years ago
it was either senator or congressman who
yelled who yelled you lie at obama
and they were like i don't remember who
but the entire media was like this is
unprecedented this level
of incivility i was like they used to
shoot each other yeah like they used to
shoot each other
but yeah it's horrible and obviously
it's it's a better place to be in where
yelling is bad
um and uh you know you're that far
removed from violence but unfortunately
it does seem we
are returning there in a lot of ways
tensions have been escalating it's kind
of crazy
when you look back a hundred years ago
uh hundreds of years ago how
like they didn't really value their own
lives all that much yeah like i would
want to duel someone because
i i've grown quite fond of living yeah
have we talked i feel like we've talked
about this before like people were just
or maybe i've had this conversation with
someone else and maybe it's the way the
past was depicted or the machismo that
people had but
yeah folks were a lot more willing to
take risks that would result in their
life
ending yeah now or not i mean maybe
maybe this thing i've got about three
teeth left
so it's probably about time anyway so
there's a few things that i wanted to uh
you know highlight with the story one is
should we have politicians who aren't
going to be scared and hide
in the bathroom while their staffers
stand guard for them
hmm you know what i mean so like i don't
blame her for being scared she didn't
know what's going on and she's you know
what's that oh sorry sorry yeah i mean i
don't i don't blame her she was scared
um
i guess is this sort of back to ian's
point about some kind of military
training for
for congress people or i don't know if
we need uh
congress people to have military
training or something like that yeah but
there there's a there's a funny issue in
the story
where she says her staffer told her it
was safe to come out
implying that she was hiding in the
bathroom and left her staffer out in the
front oh
i get that i hear you on that point yes
yeah
so so the issue i'm bringing up is
are these the people who are going to be
voting our kids into war yeah that's a
very good you know who are going to be
no they yeah exactly they should be
armed they should learn how to handle
weapons have some sort of comments
right there be armed if they're going to
be working at the capitol you know i
think that's a really good point not
necessarily because we want
uh not necessarily because we expect
that the capital is going to be
continually attacked though again you
know
hope for the best prepare for the worst
that said if if you are going to be
sending people to fight in wars and you
are going to be regulating guns
you should probably have some knowledge
of combat i say i say let's let's go a
step further
if you want to fight a war you go fight
it if the politician wants to start one
bring your sons bring yourself go out
there just like the kings did
the kings back in the day obviously you
know as you said way back
way back in the day if they wanted to
fight a war they would literally put
their brothers their sisters their whole
family on the front line they were the
ones leading the charge and i why not
bring that back
well let's even bring back dueling if
they want to do it themselves
voluntarily i mean
to me that's uh that's a that's a you
know solution that voluntarist would
really like
you need to like sign a contract like
you would be here by duel the problem
with that is
someone could be coerced into signing
something or they could yeah you don't
like it and then murder somebody
i definitely like to do oh sorry i was
gonna say there was a period where the
kings stopped doing that
and then i don't know if you guys ever
seen the movie the patriot man i i
reference the patriots
all the time where cornwallis is like
you know stop killing my officers
could you imagine the chaos of you know
no officers on the battlefield oh
like you can't you can't kill those guys
yeah just kill the little poor people
yeah it's really really horrible and i
i'm not um definitely not a fan of of
dueling but
i hear you guys very much on the fact or
on this idea that
there should be more of a a cost to the
the people waging these wars or pushing
the country into them that there isn't i
mean it's a cost that your average
person
pays or is more liable to pay and they
just don't
to me it's also kind of awkward to see
the people who create one of the worst
humanitarian crises
in the world specifically with yemen
selling weapons to saudi arabia and
allowing that
telling us about uncivility and how rude
people
are and how violent protests are i mean
the two don't really add up when you
really look at it from that perspective
yeah i mean you look at the fact that uh
boeing had like a 580 billion dollar
contract servicing the f-12s that were
being used to bomb yemen by the saudi
arabian government
well no no no the u.s saudi coalition
yeah that are working
together in tandem yeah bombing the crap
out of mainly the hootsy areas which of
course is creating the worst
humanitarian uh you know crisis
according to the united
why is it still st up and it's so long
as they want to milk it for all it's
worth
and then run these segments i'll just be
like can we get that dude who's bar
burnt down in the minneapolis riots
100 on the tv as well because i'm i'm
all down to like
aoc told their story all right i respect
that congrats you know i i hear you i
hear you
it was probably traumatic you've never
experienced before i must be must be
crazy and
sorry it happened to you um how about we
make room on the stage for the the the
businessman
who you set up a sports bar it was his
dreams a firefighter
and then it got destroyed by these
rioters how come we didn't have this
massive news cycle for this guy
and it was incumbent upon you know
independent
news channels and social media to
promote this guy to get him the support
he needed
well they're going to be talking about
this for four years minimum exactly this
is their 911. this is their harbor
this is the event that they're going to
be milking until
i don't even want to say when but i
remember even driving cows come home
yeah
yes i love it i remember just
even today driving and listening to npr
and they had a cia guy
of course who was talking about the
dangers of insurrection
domestically and specifically going on
about how we need to take down trump we
need to charge him with as much as we
can because he represents a strong guy
and there's an ideology that we need to
fight domestically
and it was bomb it was just
mind-boggling sitting back driving and
watching and seeing
a cia guy who who fought off insurgents
in the middle east
now trying to implement some of those
policies inside of the united states
domestically and when you look at biden
and the people he surrounded himself
with especially
with the laser-like focus that the
intelligence agencies under him
according to john brennan are going to
be focusing now on the libertarians and
on the nativists
we're headed towards a situation that's
not going to be clearing up
any time this is why they're going to be
talking about this insurrection
for at least at least four years i'm
surprised we're still not milking 911
uh just like rudy giuliani did every
hour basically are with the people yeah
exactly with the patriot act all this
the same laws are in effect and all the
same
overreactions are still in place you
know we're still fighting in the middle
east these wars have continued after
afghanistan and even today we got news
and information that you know germany is
pushing the united states to stay in
longer
and most likely the other information
and other reports we're getting in today
is that the withdrawal that was planned
from afghanistan is not going to happen
oh geez
so the trooper girl yeah so well so
that's what a shock that is
right the establish these listen you
know you know why i love the game stop
story
is that for once you have a clear path
to uniting
left and right on an issue they agree on
and against the establishment elites who
propagate these wars
and then we see this drama pop up which
is the distraction in my opinion on
purpose
to get us off topic to focus on stupid
drama that doesn't mean anything well
and it's funny because they go on and on
about how
it was trump who riled up these tensions
and i think it was even claimed that ted
cruz was responsible aoc insinuated that
earlier even though he said
aoc said that yeah yeah
and their whole argument is well they
propagated misinformation that
allowed for tensions to become so high
that people were willing to attack the
capital it's like all right well what
about all the lies the media told to get
us into these conflicts in the middle
east
how many people have died as a result of
that and how many of them are on camera
how many of them are we talking about do
you see the new york times call for a
reality zara
a realities are yes but that's already
what they are
isn't it but but i'm sorry they said a
task force so they'll be more like
a ministry of truth yeah they're talking
about a cross-agency
of experts coming together to tackle
disinformation
and quote domestic extremism this is
called a ministry of chance yeah
the realities are i mean but but this is
that's not even the bigger story here
the person who called for it the new
york times officially called for this
with their article by kevin rose
saying that this is a good idea and that
this is needed where have we
come where we have the new york times of
all publications the publication that by
the way
told the american people that there was
weapons of mass destruction in iraq they
were the first ones to sell that lie to
the american people
and now they're telling us we need a
ministry of truth we need a reality czar
we need to have control of information
that that that they're going to be
working with tech platforms on
along with the government making sure
that information
is of course held in the hands of the
very few
it's it's repugnant to see this here's
my favorite part so we have the article
from the new york times
it says appoint a reality czar several
experts i spoke with recommend the biden
administration put together a
cross-agency task force to tackle
disinformation and domestic extremism
which would be led by something like a
reality czar
it sounds a little dystopian i'll grant
but let's hear them out sounds
a little distilled no no no no we don't
hear them it's like a guy coming and
being like
we would like to have a camp set up
where you can take people who believe
bad things and are causing problems to
place them for for a certain period of
time
and then maybe teach them things to
change the disinformation that way
they're no longer a threat to society
and i know i know it sounds dystopian
no i'm not going to hear you out we
don't want to react with ministry of
truth in this country yeah
i'm sorry the news publication that lied
to us and led to the deaths of hundreds
of thousands of people meaninglessly
that led to a migrant crisis
is not going to be lecturing me about
how truth needs to be controlled by
central forces in the government
what they're talking about here is
essentially the tech platforms working
with
experts from agencies all around uh the
united states government to fight
conspiracy theories they're the biggest
pushers of conspiracy
and and and it's just a slap in the face
yeah yeah yeah that's one out of uh
thousands of other examples we can make
and with the new york times it goes so
much further back we were talking
about this on the show i think the last
time i was here and how the uh the
holiday morning was covered up by the
new year oh yeah they're just
won the pulitzer prize for covering
amazing um and so yeah the press has
always been horrible and yeah the idea
that they would talk about conspiracy
theories when they just spent the last
three years claiming without any
evidence that the president of the
united states was
a russian asset they're bringing it back
baby they're bringing it back
are they changing jimmy kimmel the
saying wall street vets
russia probably some russian bots how
this is like don't they
they have to understand how ridiculous
that is they do and they're laughing at
us
here's the thing when you look at
the the media channels let me let me do
this let me i'm gonna do it i'm gonna do
a segment throwback
do it i'm gonna show you this image
we're gonna drag the young turks yes
no tim i don't want to do that this is
michael tracy
he tweeted lol if you are really this
obsessed with my tweets
seek help and it is tyt
live aoc's horrifying details of capital
riot offend pathetic michael tracy
who cares about michael tracy and i mean
no disrespect
i i follow him i think he's a good
journalist but he's not he's
not like a politician who's doing
anything guy on twitter he's a
journalist this is this is ridiculous
yep
and so the the point is you look at how
the media reacts to
to these stories that's what's
acceptable
that's the kind of news that they deem
acceptable when there's a slow news day
don't try and make news just focus on
the federal reserve
break it apart i love it someone tells
me they're not going to do that anytime
soon but man do i wish i highly doubt
that
tucker carlson actually brought up the
federal reserve and the larger economic
impacts that they're having on society
which is really surprising seeing
him say hey we should be focusing on the
fed which was
just quite mind-boggling when did he do
this yesterday oh good for him yeah uh
but again uh you know
other individuals in the mainline
establishment media their lies
they're harmful and they're they're
amplified and they're promoted with
rigged algorithms that of course have
their insider buddies promoting them so
you see them first
and you have no other option even if you
search for news and even independent
news there was even a time where you
typed in and searched for my news
organization you couldn't find it
you would get articles with the
mainstream media bashing me
so so it's just absolutely ridiculous
but another layer here
we need to understand that's critically
important is that the big
tech social media companies the
technocrats are really the ones in
charge that are pushing a lot of this
nonsense that are controlling the
conversation
controlling the narratives and this is
why issues like alexandria ocasio-cortez
are being brought up
and then dunking and criticizing and
attacking individuals like jimmy dore
glenn greenwald michael tracy all of
them
is is in my opinion coordinated because
we have seen attacks on both
on three of these individuals in such a
way that that
really is perplexing because it
absolutely makes no sense
there's no rational sense to attack them
from a logical perspective what are they
going to do
you mean from an honest perspective yes
logically it makes tons of sense
michael tracy glenn greenwald jimmy dore
are all rather left-wing individuals
i wouldn't i don't necessarily think
it's fair to say michael tracy has left
wings i don't think he tweets about
supporting left-wing policy he's just
heterodox and glenn greenwald
actually is fairly progressive and jimmy
dore is definitely on the left yeah
when they challenge the machine in the
establishment it's very difficult listen
when we saw donald trump as president
you had
one side hate donald trump and this is
the point i was gonna bring up with the
young turks
think about the people who watch the
young turks and are sitting there going
like oh michael tracy like he's so
dumb like wow so stupid these people
are with all due respect not
what's the right word i want to say
without calling them a disparaging term
uh just there's there's different tiers
no no there's different tiers of
individuals there's those
that would prefer to listen to some like
hardcore boring
seven men from tajikistan were arrested
today there's like very straightforward
news
then you get people who will watch this
more conversational but a little higher
level and you get people who are like i
want to hear about
aoc yelling at michael tracy and so they
watch that kardashian
when you're trying to tell people about
what's going on and when you're trying
to convince people of policy
but you have half this country that just
mindlessly follows along these
ridiculous narratives
how do you convince them to make better
moves that will help themselves it's
very very difficult so what happens is
you get people who might begrudgingly
vote for trump why critical race theory
is bad for instance james lindsay is a
good example
he's a left-wing guy he challenges the
system
he says i'm going to vote for trump
because you know trump's better for
these reasons joe biden
is the establishment who's going to do
everything that the left hates
and everything the right hates combines
can bring all together you end up
with this very difficult scenario but in
in the media it's really easy to split
the left and the right
you got people who supported trump well
tell everybody orange man is bad most
these people who watch like the young
turks and just want to hear the drama
will believe it
what happens when you get wall street
when you get wall street bets oh boy
when you get game stop well now all of
all of a sudden these people who have
been told over and over again by the
likes of the young turk that wall street
bad
well you can't just change their mind
now and say wall street good
so so what do they do well they distract
they try and shift the focus away
they bring up aoc they want a reality
czar
to make sure that you're not thinking
about the wrong thing there was one
article in the nation
where they said that uh wall street vets
like trumpism and cubanon you see what
they try and do
exactly when when they can't give you a
dividing line on trump because half the
country hates trump
they try and shift the narrative and
give you tabloid drama well it's
hilarious though because i think a lot
of people on the left are willing to see
this with this situation now the media
might have screwed themselves here
at least to some extent because there
are a number of people on left and you
look at like reddit reddit is often
pretty left-leaning politically and so
when they see themselves being
associated with white supremacists
or with donald trump because they're
upsetting people on wall street they
they might start to think maybe these
terms don't actually mean anything
because this is also something that the
vast majority
of people who have heard of are very
much in favor of
like most people who have seen the wall
street bat story they think it's
hilarious
uh and so when you start telling them
well actually the people who are
disrupting the stock market and raising
the
the price of the stock for gamestop and
hurting this hedge fund are white
supremacists
it sort of opens up their eyes and they
think oh maybe maybe conservatives are
telling the truth when they say that
word is just thrown around or that
phrase is just thrown around it doesn't
mean anything
well you start to notice that if they're
calling of people who are having
fun with wall street vets white
supremacists they might just be calling
anyone that means that maybe you should
rethink what you're
you've been thinking about conservatives
maybe that's not what they're saying
maybe they're not telling you the truth
100 and they've overplayed their hand
and this is what they did with the word
racist they almost never say racist
anymore they always say white
supremacists because after the 2016
election they realized
that it was not effective anymore yeah
and so trump won despite the fact that
he was called racist all the time so
they said let's switch
to a heavier term let's be even more
explicit let's call them white
supremacists and so they started doing
that
and now they're calling um redditors who
are buying stock white supremacists
so they've ruined that first for
themselves too i don't know what the
next one's going to be
we saw financial times say that some of
these people were all right
and then they had to retract that and be
okay that's not true
no now they're just going for it now
they're like okay look
we need to manipulate people and the
scary thing is
that's why i mentioned the young turks
that's why i mentioned the michael tracy
story
there are people who will just literally
believe whatever the media puts out
that's it and they'll follow whatever
story the media tells them to follow
and then you have the grifter lefties on
youtube who'll be like slay queen
woo and it's like weren't you just mad
at wall street like without without
naming this particular individual
you have one guy who's like antifa is
good you know
and they're they're destroying small
businesses and whatever but it's because
they're fighting the machine
then 25 000 troops get to deploy get
deployed to dc
and they literally lock down the entire
city in a military occupation and the
same guy
who was cheering antifa goes this is a
good thing i'm in favor of the military
lockdown i'm like dude
do you have any real opinions you're
just supporting whatever it is
the right doesn't like i think the
problem i have with this
conversation is that we're like okay
this fire
is burning and destroying things and see
i'm scooping
fuel into the fire right now we're gonna
scoop some fuel into this fire by
talking about it no you're wrong that's
what we're doing right now
we're spreading water but you're saying
look having this conversation
is scooping fuel in just so you know
because we're becoming the media that's
talking about it you're wrong
we're spraying water on it right now i i
wholeheartedly disagree when we bring
this crap up
and go talk about this junk we're
propelling it but
we're acknowledging that that is what
we're doing so so when we're showing
people this
this if you're if you're if you're
falling for this and you're talking
about it you're fueling it
so when we literally do a segment saying
don't fall for the tricks of the media
and the manipulation and focus on what
matters
we're making it worse we're like we're
like don't fall for this
and we're doing it what are we doing
we're fueling the fire what fire what
are you talking about the fire of
michael we're specifically [ __ ] crap
this is the media's manipulation
and we're focusing on the new york times
calling for abide in reality czar
to manipulate what you can know if we
don't talk about that and people don't
know they're doing it
then they'll get away with it we're not
talking about aoc that's why we're like
criticizing the young turks this is
how the fire is fueled that's what we're
doing right now and we're doing it and
we're showing them this is how it's done
this is the fire the
the fire is when you get left-wing
channels like the young turks
telling you not like creating content
that shifts your focus away from high
level issues like media manipulation
and hedge fund manipulation and tells
you to pay attention to some dude on
twitter
what we're doing is we're calling that
out a step back and saying
don't let the media manipulate you so
you you need to pay attention to wall
street and to pay attention to the head
funds
and don't let them divide us i'm not
going to sit here and rag on aoc because
she was scared
i respect her telling her story i
understand why she was scared i think
what
i think what she does when she promotes
stuff is bad politically because she's
essentially just using
whether she knows it or not these pr
tactics to shift the narrative onto her
to build up more
you know press attention and things like
that and i fully recognize that we give
her attention we talk about it i'm not
super worried about that
my issue is they want us fighting they
want us
mad at aoc they want us yelling at her
no i would like her to actually tweet
more about wall street and hedge funds i
respected that i i praised that
rasheed taleb as well i don't want them
to divide us and i think it's important
that we sit here and say
look where the look look what the new
york times is now saying biden should
have a reality czar a task force
to stop disinformation but we're calling
them out for being the liars he makes me
think have you ever read 1984
it's a it's a the orwell book there's a
point yeah the ministry of truth is like
this realities are in the book they have
this hour of hate
where every day they have everybody sits
in front of the tv for an hour and just
thinks about hate and that's like what
this stuff is they're
you know they're just trying to drive
people i think it can be agree
i would disagree because i think that
what alexandria ocasio-cortez is doing
is very clever and very cynical and
something that no one has really touched
on is the fact that she's talking about
cops
she's rolling it into her own rhetoric
and she's talking about how the cop made
her feel
unsafe that's a very clever way of
bringing your ideas into the
conversation
and bringing emotion in with it as well
you were terrified it was a cop you
didn't know if you were going to be like
poor george floyd or whoever has been
most recently assaulted by a policeman
you keep bringing up constantly i i
think it's fair to
disagree with with with aoc but when i
like i mentioned earlier like she does
this instagram thing and i'm kind of
like okay
like that's fine i understand her story
okay
but what's happening now is rolling
stone newsweek young turks etc
are are putting this into everyone's
face that's fire
we are telling you don't get distracted
by the drama don't let the manipulation
and the low
level you know conversations dominate
your minds
so what we're doing now is we're
discussing the idea of media
manipulation
a ministry of truth realities are
because in my opinion
if they did have a reality czar first of
all that's psychotic it's insane
but it would essentially their goal
would be to make sure we don't talk
about these conversations we don't
we we just had luke calling out you know
the human right human rights abuses in
yemen
we're talking about voting for war and
and these and these
emotionally manipulative tactics they
don't want us talking about it and i
mean
like the new york times the politicians
they want us distracted
they want to take a story aoc put out
that has no bearing on my life or anyone
else's
and make it a major news story so we
stopped talking about
hedge funds and wall street and the
short sellers
which we're talking about now that's the
point of this segment that's the point
of doing things like have you heard that
statement uh that the phrase by marshall
mcluhan he says the medium
is the message and in that sense if we
choose to spend two hours talking about
the problems in the media
we've actually become the problem in the
media how does that make sense because
we're
stooping to that level we're slinging
we're acknowledging the mud but in order
to do that we have to get in the mud
so it's good to talk about it i pointed
out but to revel in it
is like if we spent we've already spent
40 minutes talking about it so we have
two different issues first we addressed
the tabloid drama nonsense
and how it distracted we shifted into
the new york times wanting to have a
reality czar and what that means for the
country
and so the way i see it is look you've
got a problem if you want to put a fire
out and save the people from the fire
you gotta run into a burning building
so we could choose not to talk about any
of this and let it fester and grow and
get worse
or we can use our platform to challenge
it and say
this is this is bs and we have to call
it out to address it as a problem
and then quite literally what we're
doing is the solution
letting people see and hear our ideas
and if they agree with us then those
ideas propagate
you've changed my mind oh there we go
nice
awesome you know and i have to say man
i've never seen you that fired up about
anything on the podcast i actually
really appreciate it haven't you ever
seen the
arguments we've had it's good times no
no i guess not enough of them
they're out there he got fired up that
was uh yeah i haven't seen that for me
media manipulation it's a double-edged
sword watching i hear you yeah
it's it's look it's a double-edged sword
right so i i've done numerous videos
ragging on democrats
recognizing that it's it's it's
convenient for the establishment to have
the partisan divide
but how do you and this is why i love
the gamestop story
how are you supposed to point out that
it typically is
democrats causing the problems don't get
me wrong don't get me wrong republicans
to a great degree causing problems never
there's just slightly more republicans
than democrats who are doing better but
they're all
they're all just so awful right so when
you have
donald trump and his critics are so
insane that you're like this is not
legitimate criticism of a president
and you need to call it out i get emails
from people all the time saying how do i
convince
my family members that the media is
lying to them and i'm like
show them the truth and they're like
yeah but they don't believe it they
don't they they don't want to watch the
news
they don't want when i send them a link
saying here's the real video of donald
trump and say i'm not watching that
and now it's really really simple show
them reddit.com
and then google search reddit silver
and then what you see is on google all
of these news stories
you know dozens hundreds saying reddit
says buy silver
and then show them reddit.com do not buy
silver
it's there the veil has been shattered
now we're getting this tabloid drama
trying desperately to shift the
narrative away to something
unfalsifiable
this story about aoc and michael tracy
is a really good example
it's a of an excellent manipulation
tactic there's no right or wrong answer
it is a tribal agreement or disagreement
do you not like aoc do you like aoc
therefore there's no way to look at that
story and call it fake news
they've been able to now attempt this
media attack
to trick boomers for the most part into
buying silver when reddit was saying
don't
do it when people started to see how
they were lying and manipulating
they said go for an emotionally driven
headline that will dominate the press
and manipulate people into reading news
that can't be right or wrong 100
yeah and that's what's so insidious it's
it's the stories that aren't fake like
you said this is something that actually
happened as he's actually talking about
this
but there is something we're being
distracted from
the easiest way the most important take
away from the whole thing
is this the story isn't true or false
and that's what's important for them get
everybody emotionally charged up
demanding their right but being but it's
impossible because it's an opinion
well i can tell you one thing that's
true or one thing it's false reddit did
not say buy silver
and the media did lie when they claimed
reddit did
that is the red pill like that is a red
pill
that you can literally just hand to
somebody and there's it's like it's like
dissolves in their skin
you know what you gotta put in their
mouth you just show them these two
things and they're gonna be like that's
that's insane so immediately what
happens is they run full speed and smack
it out of your hand because they don't
want you to show people what's actually
going on
that's the point of these narratives
that's why the story was trending on
twitter
not and it's not necessarily because
like i think anyone conspired to make it
happen
what i think happens typically is you've
got pr people who look for opportunities
to shift the narrative
i don't think anybody had a meeting and
they were like hey oc can you do a video
and do this and then we're gonna try and
you know
highlight some individual cr what
happened was she told the story
a bunch of special interests who want to
shift the narrative saw the opportunity
and use their pr tactics to do so you
know i got a little distracted by jake
paul fighting ben askren
that's going to happen off of the side
track there uh
just to add up to your point here we
also have to understand the mainstream
media has been incentivized ever since
donald trump to understand that
smash smash is good it creates more hits
it creates more views it creates more
uh advertisement revenue for them and
when you're building a huge hammer that
is just meant to destroy
what are you going to do when donald
trump your biggest nail is gone
well you're going to go you're going to
go after all the other nails jimmy dore
glenn greenwald
michael tracy who are supposedly on your
side but they're not going along with
the agenda
they're not going along with the special
interest they're not going along with of
course the big money
that of course want a specific agenda
done
they're the ones that are standing in
the way of it and of course the
mainstream media what are they going to
do look at their coverage i i think it
was the hill
that wrote an article today about how
michelle obama
got some garden vegetables from jill
biden articles like that are not going
to sell
they're not going to get clicks no one
gives a damn about their propaganda puff
piece about
glorifying the first ladies of this
country
what's going to get clicks is drama it's
fighting
smash smash smash and that's exactly
what they're doing and now they're going
after anyone that stands in their way
and it's not just going to be jimmy dore
glenn greenwald michael tracy it's going
to be
anyone anyone who even dares to peep in
the wrong direction
against the establishment's train and
their agenda that they want to shove
down your throat i think the young turks
is one of the greatest thing one of the
greatest assets for the establishment
because they come off as
anti-establishment but boy do they love
and help the establishment yeah like
when jimmy dore
was saying force the vote on medicare
for all use the leverage the
progressives have against the
establishment
you know corporate democrats the young
turks went after him
insulted him derided him and said it's
not the time
and defended the establishment while
pretending they weren't really defending
the establishment
saying oh no jimmy dore is going to help
the republicans win
see jimmy isn't going with the
establishment narrative
the young turks are so surprise surprise
they do a drama story they
they did they ran some second about me
being ugly i guess i'm like really
impressed with your news coverage
good journalism right there is it does
it listen
does it matter i'll tell you what
matters media manipulation
is tricking you into losing focus and
they're taking away from you
they're taking away your ability to
understand the world when
you when when you see these low brow
conversations about nonsense you are
being hurt
when you hear things like this and
hopefully they're i'm assuming most of
people listening
already know a lot of this they
understand that's why they're watching
this show in the first place
but there are a lot of people who
probably don't i am i am
you know look i've brought up the
gamestop silver thing so many times
because you cannot you cannot disprove
it is the perfect
red pill period you could say oh they
lied about donald trump here and people
be like oh you're crazy you just love
trump
they hate trump so much they won't
listen you could show them the video
abc did where they manipulated they
zoomed in so you didn't see shinzo abe
dump the food in
and then they show trump doing it and
claim look look at trump he's a [ __ ]
so you can try and show them the full
video of the charlottesville
comments trump made the verifying people
hoax but they don't
want to believe it they hate trump well
who likes wall street
nobody boom drop the red pill give it to
people and show them what the media has
been doing to them
so so tim when you talk about
unfalsifiable do you think this has to
do with the
the media's shift toward turning opinion
into news because i feel like every time
you read a news article it's not
actually news it's all opinions and they
call it analysis now
yeah to be fair what i do is much the
same
you know what i mean it's it's it's my
opinion and my take on things i guess
you do your homework
but i guess it's true i try and factor
everything but the i guess the main
difference is my opinions aren't
particularly strong
and i avoid framing devices for the most
part so
uh actually that's probably not fair to
say i pr i probably frame things the way
i do it you know
in a similar way but i'm just not on
anyone's side for the most part
well we all have a bias and it's about
you know being
acknowled acknowledging that bias like i
obviously have some experiences that
makes me distrust
the state and the government especially
after looking at a lot of history and
having some personal experiences but
it's about admitting it
and being honest with it having a
conversation that's actually genuine
not scripted trying to push an agenda
over the truth
so i think that's the biggest difference
that we see from you know
let's just say us compared to of course
jimmy kimball
who's given a line about russia being
involved
somehow in this reddit scandal and just
blanketly
soullessly reading it to the american
viewer like it's truth when we know
it's just scripted there's a lot of big
money behind it and there's also a huge
agenda behind it that doesn't serve the
american people it does the
exact opposite of that it screws them
over
let's talk about joe biden yes let's
let's let's not let's not got hairy legs
yes he does yes yes you do joe and they
and they what does he say
his hair shines it shines when you rub
rub your hand down it
i am going to have so much fun over the
next four years i'm actually
i'm really sad the reason i and i
discuss this right after um
the election but i'm horribly sad
because
millions more unborn children will
likely die um and
then would have otherwise and uh
thousands more people in the middle east
there's gonna be a horrible horrible
presidency
so i'm not happy about it but um he's
he's certainly an interesting target to
go after and i think he sort of exposes
a lot of the problems with the system
when you look at the fact that the
dominant media culture was worshiping
this man
that's also sort of a red pill moment
because a lot of progressives don't like
him they feel bernie sanders was robbed
and uh they don't like harris yeah for
sure and
when you look at kamala harris too they
don't like her either
and so it's getting to the point where
the people they prop up and make into
idols
are so universally disliked that that in
and of itself
is red pilling the public yeah i've got
like a a
sense of like relief right now that
trump's not in office because of the
drama
and and distractions that he would cause
with news
articles yeah and now it's like it's
gone there's nothing else to look at so
we're looking at gamestop we're looking
at the economy
and but they're trying to shift it back
i know they want that drama back that's
what a silver line still it's like
it's like 10 of what it was three weeks
ago like i haven't had to look at
trump's face in like three
i see his face every couple days someone
will message me a picture of trump i'm
like
dude that guy is not relevant right now
that he really never was he was he was
the president but he's not
well he was pretty relevant
the system is the relevancy and the
people that are are in these positions
are coming and going
it's that economy that messed up a cop
here's
here look look look i would say you know
with trump's tweets
it really made sure the spotlight was
always on trump and it was
bad for him in a lot of ways like
sometimes it was like
there were a few things he just didn't
tweet he would have you know if you have
if he was banned sooner he might have
gotten re-elected
yeah no joke no joke um because he he
kind of hurt himself in some of these
major stories with the things he was
tweeting about you know and just
generating more news if trump didn't say
anything and went radio silent for a
month the media would would have starved
to death
like a parasite just like you know no
longer like a leech falling off and then
just like
withering away i was kept cnn's ratings
dropped
44 the week that trump left office yeah
they were just the trump network yep
that was it that's all they talked about
and they weren't doing well before he
came along either it's not as if they've
been doing great and then
trump left office and now they're down i
was like they were doing horribly then
trump was elected
and then they were doing pretty well and
now he's gone and they've got nothing
look at this story
this is from variety is that what you
were citing yes cnn primetime ratings
fall back to earth in first
post-trump week back to earth it's over
you know look i obviously i voted for
donald trump and
uh would have preferred him greatly to
joe biden but there is a bit of me
that's relieved
that without trump listen a good analogy
is that
trump was a very large man that provided
the life force for the energy vampires
that were
the mainstream media just sucking all of
that energy wasn't it was it's near
infinite
donald trump's dragon energy sustained
the media for years they were collapsing
before trump
yes the ceo of vice said there was gonna
be a bloodbath in digital media
and it didn't happen the layoffs
reversed because donald trump came along
and he just exuded media energy yeah
and they they all started like little
gremlins crawling towards it then
absorbing the energy
and now trump is gone and they're all
like hissing and chasing after people
it's kind of like when the people you
know the cove locked down in new york
and the rats came out of the ground
started chasing people because they're
desperate and hungry
and they're fighting squirrels and stuff
it's happening now
the president of cnn is apparently like
looking at other jobs
jim acosta is got he's he was
transferred out of the white house and
they're putting in that other woman
it's over it's done his behavior on
twitter created an entire genre of jobs
the trump reply guy people
yeah exactly what are they doing now
what are the trump reply guys gonna do
donald trump gave us a gift you know
what he did what it's kind of like
the media are these energy vampires that
look for insane drama to manipulate
and they're like lurking in the shadows
jumping out writing fake news and they
were smearing people like jordan
peterson
that famous interview so what you're
saying is and it went viral because
people were like this is nuts
but the vampires were leaching off of
people donald trump stepped in
and then like you goku going super
saiyan went ah and then energy
burst off of his body and dro drew all
of the attention to himself
now these people have forgotten how to
sustain themselves
the media outlets built as you mentioned
a genre
or there's a reply guy but the media
also created a genre reporting on trump
because of that a lot of people shifted
their normal beat
a lot of news organizations fired
certain journalists that covered real
news and hired people just to cover
trump
then when trump ascended and vanished
from sight
all of these people are left just
desperate and hungry and they don't
know how to feed anymore now we're going
to see a glorious collapse and
starting with cnn whose ratings have
fallen back to earth
they say back to earth well tim that's
your understanding of it for me
it was trump just taking dumps and these
rats eating it
and and now trump's not taking any more
dumps i think ian would agree with that
one
and now and now the rats are going or
going hungry and they're going to start
eating their own very soon okay
okay hold on it was donald trump taking
a dump and then the flies landing yes
yes okay that's that's more fair have we
consulted with the truth
czar on this oh no no we should yeah i
have a ouija board now
oh my god no no no please no
look at this they say uh while january
21 2021 will go down in the ratings
record books for cnn
the last week of the month may offer a
portent of what the post-trump era will
be like for the network
in the first week of the biden
administration the att owned news
channel saw audiences
that had been flooding into prime time
recently dropped precipitously
from january 25th 29th compared with the
highs of the previous weeks
meanwhile rival fox news channel saw its
own ratings only dipped slightly
yeah after weeks of registering its own
sharp declines i wonder how msnbc
did another network they mentioned msnbc
has also seen significant declines but
nowhere near as steep as what has hit
cnn
variety intelligence platform analysis
of the viewership data across two key
metrics
the target news demographic for people
ages 25 to 54
and the total audience watching shows
that cnn ended the final week of january
with ratings dropping roughly 44 for
total audience
versus the prior week oh man
look at that that is that is that is
massive
fox news dropped only four point four
percent and at nine pm five point nine
eight percent
now fox news uh uh at eight p.m actually
it looks like they increased
they're the only ones who actually went
off tucker 8pm there you go that's
tucker yep
so we can see msnbc is a massive decline
cnn is a massive decline
because their ratings were artificial it
was a new
genre the trump story 24 7. they turned
the apprentice
into politics exactly or a good point
yeah
now that he's gone oh they're fired all
these like yeah
exactly you guys ever seen the movie day
breakers i've quoted i've mentioned this
before too
it's where uh you know everybody's
basically turned into a vampire and
there's very few humans left
so the vampires have nothing to feed on
and they all start fighting each other
and turning into these horrible monsters
and like
there's a scene where there's like a
vampire in a coffee stand and they put
blood in the coffee because you know the
vampires
and then she puts in a little bit and he
goes give me more blood and then she's
like i can't he's like give me more on
the attack sir
that's what's happening with the media
that's what's going to happen next
if you i've talked about it before if
you thought the fake news was bad
back then wait until they're starved
and and hungry it's like you you know
you got a vampire right he feeds when he
when he feels like it
but now he hasn't fed in weeks he's
going to jump out of the shadows and
latch onto anything and anyone
or a better analogy i guess is the rats
in new york city
once the tourists are gone the rats
started coming out in packs and hunting
squirrels and other random animals
there's apparently like a video
where like a pigeon and a rat were
fighting because they're starving to
death
that's what's gonna happen to the news
media so they're gonna write crazy
things
like just you wait and they start
writing this crazy crazy stuff they're
gonna get more and more insane
they're still writing about donald trump
yeah i know they're still what i think
about trump yeah
like we were just talking about it they
blame wall street bets on trumpism trump
ism and that's gonna be
it is trumpism that's what they're gonna
keep referring to now that he's gone
they sure missed that trump crap
i mean exactly absolutely they got
addicted they got addicted
i remember even before donald trump
became president there was a lot of
discussion about the mainstream media
dying
but also there was a lot of conversation
about it not just dying and going away
but it
going more into the hands of wall street
firms which
a lot of them are invested into the
mainstream media and also other
billionaires so
today we got the news that the amazon
ceo jeff bezos is stepping down
and he's not really you know quitting or
retiring he's just going to be
refocusing
on things like his satellite company
things like his contracts with the us
government but
most importantly what i found surprising
is he's going to be focusing
on the washington post which essentially
has been acting
like his mouthpiece the mouthpiece of
the billionaire class especially with
all the crazy articles that we've been
seeing from them
i mean they called people who believe in
guns white supremacists
they call the the the wall street bets
people what did they
they said that that the hedge funds guys
are the good guys
every single talking point is like some
kind of pompous elite
douche [ __ ] uh family friends can i say
uh i don't know definitely
douche flute that's having his pinky and
lecturing you about how better and more
important they are than you
so when we look at the washington post i
think the mainstream media model is
going to go
more towards them more bastardized more
controlled by special interest
it already is on such a massive level
it's only going to get worse from here
the washington post is the outlet that
ran the article saying the hedge funds
are the good guys
yes yes the little guy so what's really
interesting is with the story of wall
street bets
is that i was reading and factually on
this one but i was reading posts where
they said
because of the short sellers gamestop
struggled to have a quorum in their
investors meeting
because the people who were investing
weren't showing up there was there were
no people
because they weren't legitimate
investors and that was bankrupting the
company it was causing very serious
problems
they need to have these shareholders
meetings to talk about how the company
pulls through and they survive so
they're effectively
betting to destroy these companies and
literally strangling them out
that's when we see the washington post
yeah not those that are challenging that
machine and that's bezos and you're
saying that's what he's he's now going
to go focus on
there was already a trend before yeah
yeah that's one of the things as he's
stepping down from amazon he's going to
be refocusing his efforts
on one of them is going to be the
washington post but even before donald
trump there's a lot of conversations
about wall street getting involved in
mainstream media
and killing any form of investigative
journalism because it wasn't as
profitable
as of course it was the the sensational
celebritard nonsense that they push on
us and that's essentially what they've
become
my friends i am going to give you a very
clippable moment
so uh i don't i think youtube can do it
but uh here's the clip
luke you mentioned that wall street was
destroying investigative journalism
sir you are correct and i'll break it
down for it's very simple if you go
to an investor and say i would like to
start a media outlet that does
investigative journalism the investor
says okay
how much money do you need and they say
for the first year we're looking at five
hundred thousand dollars to hire a small
team of journalists and producers
to research these stories and produce
the content wonderful excellent
what can i expect on my return well we
don't know for sure because we have to
do the investigation
the investor then says so you mean to
tell me i can give you the money
and i might get zero dollars back i
might just lose 100 of my investment
because you don't even know what's going
to happen with what with your
investigations that's correct sir
why would i invest in that meanwhile
another dude walks up and goes
yo i'm going to write about
ocasio-cortez and michael tracy it's
going to cost me 50 bucks to hire some
23 year old
give me five grand i'll turn it into 50
grand overnight or an
intern for free yeah well you can't do
that anymore so
uh they can't do core functions this is
i literally experienced this at these
news outlets these digital platforms
i was there and it was very very simple
i would like to do an investigation i
need a hundred grand to do it
no way are we gonna do that because i
can get some 23 year old
at minimum wage to write about
ocasio-cortez and michael tracy and
that's going to get me a million views
and make me some real money so why would
i invest
in investigative journalism and that's
the most important journalism we need
people
seeking out the corruption exposing the
corruption and it's dangerous
you could get killed you could have your
life destroyed you could be framed for
crimes they will do everything to
destroy you if you truly were seeking to
expose them
look how hard they go after project
veritas yeah well there's also a lot of
liability
i mean me and you did investigative
journalism a lot of times we put our
lives on the line to do so a lot of
times there's
you know insurance companies involved in
this and there's a lot of risk that
you're going to be have you're going to
have to be responsible for as a company
so that's another reason why we are
seeing the decline of any form of
investigations
and this new form of reactionary kind of
bull crap
that is being incentivized and again it
could be because of you know the risk it
could be
what you mentioned but also another
factor here as i've been talking about
is the algorithms that promote the the
sensationalist garbage then of course
give them
money give them clicks give them ad
revenue as well yeah so what do you guys
think the solution is
um giant meteor just just
ripping through the earth i gotta be
honest the problems would all be gone
kidding
we inspire people to subsidize
investigative journalism well yeah of
course but the question like how do we
do that how do we get
well so first i'll say thank you for
that tim's doing it well first with
subverses
i'll say that the problem is when
politics was hyper partisan
because some people just hated trump so
much they wanted an outlet to watch and
just revel in their hatred
and then you had people who loved trump
and hated the other side the culture war
was in full swing
now we're going to see how the evolution
takes place with biden the establishment
in in control
it might open up the door for more
reasonable investigative reporting
but the the outlets that did
investigative reporting were almost
entirely
progressive and so the the stories they
would investigate were almost
exclusively framed anti-trump negative
towards the right
and it wasn't in my opinion getting to
the core of our problems
it would be like donald trump's got a
golden toilet and we secretly got
recording of him
making his maid clean it or something
and it's like i get it you don't like
trump
they did a ton of stories where they
were good investigations but kind of
just
over the top and just not the most
important thing in the world
like war for instance but yeah there
were
there were stories that you know
journalists who who do
and have done great jobs covering war
and foreign policy the problem was
people didn't want it even the
investigative outlets that existed that
were non-profit didn't want it so the
issue now is
if we have non-profit investigative
outlets they're mission driven
they're nonprofits so what's their
mission you can look at project veritas
and you know they're i i think it's fair
to say they're conservative i don't know
would you
that's the easiest way to explain no
i just they're just really radical so
well so
i'll put it this way they they i i think
it's fair to say that james o'keefe is a
conservative
but the outlet itself targets powerful
institutions
and seeks out corruption so when they go
after google i i love this criticism of
veritas they say they're conservatives
who target left-wing you know
organizations to make them look bad
when i heard that the first time i was
like so when they did the story on
google
google's a left-wing institution no no
wait wait wait we don't mean that we
don't mean that
so look i'm not i'm a fan of veritas i'm
pointing out
that even veritas has their perspective
and they and they have certain issues
they think are more important they will
cover
so the issue is i suppose i don't think
you're going to make money
on investigative journalism for the most
part i think you can
create maybe a subscription model and
then have the content sustained that way
but it's probably going to rely on
people who want to support it
yeah the purpose of it was never to make
money it was to expose
corruption and and do it you know make
bro
in better society it was it was always
marketing this is what i did
no this is true the goal real
investigation yes it was doing it for a
purpose
news organizations would have
investigate investigative journalism
because they know a sensational story on
the cover would generate positive press
attention for their paper
so the back back in the day if you did a
story was like breaking
big company is corrupt and they put it
on the front page they would sell the
most papers
and that would boost their hey look our
circulation's huge you got to pay for
pay more for ads now and we're getting
the circulation prices today
the easiest way to get traffic is not
going to be a brig
big groundbreaking story woodward and
bernstein whatever it's going to be
aoc smackdown michael tracy what
well boom clapback snapback oh million
views well even if you did
do some incredible investigative
journalism and you're just starting off
no one will see it because the
algorithms wouldn't promote it no matter
how good it is
people who start off as if they're not
with cnn if they're not with the
establishment if they don't have any big
money not even just money but if they
don't have any connections to google
no one's going to see their stories
let's just be honest here yeah yeah
and that's that's horrible and that's
that's the system that youtube is
building
and it needs to fix and correct me
you say fix this is exactly the intended
consequence yes
so we had there there was there was one
journalist i don't remember
who this was but it was um i forgot his
ass i'm not pronouncing that same you
know you know that jordan guy
is it chiron i don't i don't know how to
pronounce it i don't know i don't
remember his last name
i don't follow him all that much but he
was tweeting about someone who covered
the the capital riots had their video
taken down youtube just got rid of it
no ford fisher was also impacted by this
shacktail
but there was uh is that what yeah his
last name shocktell
s-c-h-s-c-h-a now you're talking about
somebody else
the point is there were a couple a
couple lefties who were pointing out
that hard coverage legitimate journalism
from the capital was deleted by youtube
and then you have ford fisher who's more
of a libertarian had his his coverage
deleted by youtube
youtube is anti-journalism so when we
were doing subverse stuff
youtube has just demonetized and
deranked and knocked all that stuff down
it's not scanner
and uh we're you know for those that are
following and are you know
we're still working on scanner and we'll
we got some stuff to work through we'll
get to that
long story short i'm hoping to subsidize
legitimate on-the-ground reporting and
investigative journalism it's just very
hard to do in this day and age
one of the big issues as well is that
many
investigative reporters don't want to
work for anybody they're just like i'll
do it on my own type of patreon and then
the reach is dramatically limited
i think interesting um phenomena when it
came to subverse and when it comes to it
it seems like the people that invested
because it was like a crowdfunded
investment
raised like a million dollars and it was
but the people i don't think i can only
really speak for myself i also invested
in it or
tried to before that got close the
investment round got closed didn't
invest to see a return on their money
they invested because they believed in
the movement which is why most
i think not investigative outlets are
non-profit is it easier just to take
donations to do it
yeah so it's it's it's not an easy
it's not it's not it's not an easy
problem to solve man the the current
internet ecosystem greatly supports snap
back clap back
uh tabloid drama over legitimate
exposing
listen man you gotta you ask some some
young person there's no culture there's
no unity and there's no passion
why should any gen zer coming up right
now going to school
want to risk their lives exposing the
corrupt
it's going to destroy their lives look
at that dude
what's his name gary webb remember that
do you know the story i just saw a video
yesterday oh yeah that's a very very
important story
yup yup what happened uh he was trying
to expose was it the cia
well the the drug trade specifically
organized by the cia that was
also arming rebels in latin america
for the overthrow of of the government
specifically the contras in nicaragua
and he exposed through talking to
individuals like freeway ricky ross
not the rapper the original real freeway
ricky ross i actually talked to him and
interviewed him on my channel on we are
change who exposed essentially how
it was the cia that introduced him to
crack cocaine and pushed crack cocaine
into the united states and can i read i
i gotta i gotta read this
this is from wikipedia you don't gotta
like wikipedia i'm just gonna read a
sentence webb was found dead
in his cara michael home uh carmichael
home on december 10 2004 with two
gunshot wounds to the head his death was
ruled a
suicide by the sacramento county
coroner's office
after a local people reported that he
had died from multiple gunshots
the coroner's office received so many
calls asking about webb's death that
sacramento county coroner robert lyons
issued a statement confirming
that webb had died by suicide when asked
by local reporters about the possibility
of two gunshots being a suicide lions
replied
it's unusual in a suicide case to have
two shots but it has been done in the
past
and it is in fact a distinct possibility
news coverage noted
that there were widespread rumors on the
internet at the time that webb had been
killed as retribution for his dark
alliance series
published eight years before webb's
ex-wife susan bell told reporters that
she believed
webb had died by suicide the way he was
acting it would be hard for me to
believe it was anything but suicide she
said
according to bell webb had been unhappy
for some time over his inability to get
a job
at another major newspaper he had sold
his house the week before his death
because he was unable to afford the
mortgage after webb's death a collection
of his stories
before after dark alliance series were
published et cetera et cetera
there was even a movie uh surrounding
history it's possible
that he shot himself in such a way that
it wasn't
lethal but most people read that and go
like they're even telling us on
wikipedia that people were like what
you got the messenger was i think the
movie that
uh documented his life and i remember
reading his book the dark alliance when
i was in
in high school and being absolutely
flabbergasted at the connections that he
was able to investigate to look into
and expose with evidence with proof
the us government literally financing
not only
death squads in latin america and and
financing revolutions and and
meddling in other people's elections but
more more importantly
bringing crack cocaine into the united
states and introducing it
into urban dense communities which of
course led to individuals like joe biden
and the clintons passing very strict
legislation that threw a lot of people
in jail for victimless crimes like using
narcotics and again just just the
weaponization
and how crack cocaine was used to
destroy
modern america those implications when
we talk about you know
racism and race issues why doesn't
anyone anyone want to bring up these
issues
why aren't we having huge conversations
about any liability for all those people
involved any consequences for all those
people involved that destroyed so many
lives and communities for
what it's absolutely sickening i mean
his book the dark alliance i definitely
recommend it and
later on in life he did complain because
no one wanted to hire him because he
exposed the cia
and when you expose the cia i mean
chuck schumer says
you guys know the story of michael
hastings he was investigating some very
very powerful people
long story short but i i can pull it up
and read it for you are you going to get
a shot
am i going to go are we no but i think
i'll get banned
yeah that's why i keep telling everybody
like we're setting up a website because
we are we are cutting through the bs and
people want to know about investigative
journalism they want to know why it's
not happening i'll tell you first you
get stories like gary webb
suicide by two gunshots to the head and
they're like trust us that's what
happened and the journalists are like yo
we got an issue with that story then you
get this story about michael hastings
and this is only
uh this is now just about seven and a
half or so years ago
controversy over alleged follow play
michael hastings was a journalist
and he died in a fiery car wreck in uh i
believe it was los angeles
that's right this was in like what 2013
2013 yeah
it wasn't joe biggs his friends well let
me let me just read this for you they
say the day before the crash hastings
indicated that he believed he was being
investigated by the fbi
in an email to colleagues who just
copied a copy to and released by
hastings
friend army staff sergeant joe biggs
hastings said that he was onto a big
story that he needed to go off the radar
and that the fbi might interview him
wikileaks announced that hastings had
also contacted jennifer robinson one of
his lawyers
a few hours prior to his death and the
la weekly reported that he was preparing
new reports on the
cia come on yeah come on come on luke
where's the queue at the time of his
death
the fbi released a statement denied that
hastings was ever under investigation by
the agency et cetera et cetera
but uh here here i want i want to give
you the gist of the story
he goes to his neighbor and he says i
need to borrow your car
because the other night i saw someone
fiddling around with my car and his
neighbor was like
that's crazy no you can't use my car
then his car was
seen speeding down the road at maximum
speed sparks and flames shooting out and
then crashed into a tree
just at the time he was saying that he
was going to be reporting on the cia
and was contacting wikileaks and uh i
guess we'll never know
i'm sure there were sparks and flames
that's what the report said wow well
there's that's what the
video uh there's like a short clip of
showing the actual
you know car moving uh before it
you know it crashed and it killed him
there's a guy named kevin ship
he used to work for this year are you
familiar with his work at all luke
you're gonna love this guy
he left the cia to expose them wrote a
book called from the shadows about the
shadow government and the deep state and
the difference between the two and he
talks
very clearly about how the cia will and
try to do to him first destroy your
economic ability to get a job
then go after your family to freak you
out then eventually they'll try and kill
you yeah
so maybe we should change subjects come
on girl find a girl
the cartoon guys i just want to make fun
of you guys
you're on the list now i'm kidding it's
true it's over i've been on the list
my big red pill with the cia and well
first of all the past four years of
just seeing the um intelligence
community trying to unseat a
democratically elected president with
absolutely no evidence was enough of a
red pill
but one thing i'm going to tell the
people at home that blew my mind the
first time i did it and i'm not even
going to describe it but just google
operation northwoods if you haven't
already oh yeah just google that i'm not
even going to tell you what it is
yeah but but the intercept what you were
talking about i kind of want to add on
the intercept actually wrote an article
a few years ago in 2014 that was titled
how the cia watched over the destruction
of
gary webb so there's a lot of other
involvement there's a lot of other
underhanded things that we don't know of
that that should be exposed
should be talked about no matter what
the consequences because the truth here
matters
but there's also other media
institutions like the washington post
which i have to point out
do have a lot of connections to the cia
that wrote an article saying quote gary
webb was no
journalism hero despite what
uh killed the messenger says kill the
messenger we're getting always getting
the movie about it
you check it out what is your argument
ian you mentioned
i i gotta address something ian just
said about how they go after your family
what i what i was told by some other
journalists is that
the first thing they do is bribe it's
simple it's simple hey would you like to
uh help us out man you know we all we
love this country
maybe we should keep talking about this
well so so they they come to you and
they
they make a very well actually it's not
it's not the first thing isn't cash the
first thing is
will you agree to work with us and a lot
of journalists say yes
immediately we'll send you stories you
publish them it'll be great it'll help
the country out and they say you got it
because these journals are like oh i'm
going to get these juicy sources these
intelligence people are going to be
feeding me the big news and then i'll
make a name for myself
you say no you say i'm not here to serve
the
the interests of the intelligence
agencies i am a journalist and they go
okay
shortly after they'll be like we want
you to work for us we can compensate you
the next incentive is money and if you
say i'm not driven by money you can't
control me i'm going to report the facts
the next thing that comes is the threats
what would happen to your family
what do you think is going to happen if
you do this powerful people are mad at
you
then you start getting signs that they
will come for you they will threaten
your family they will hurt your family
and then lastly they come for you accuse
you of crimes
smear you or ultimately kill you i'm not
saying that's true i'm saying i've had
journalists explain this to me
around this time you know in 2012 2013
with like a lot of the big hacker stuff
that was going on a lot of the
journalists that i knew and hung out
with were like this is typically what
you'll see
and so you'll end up with someone like
perhaps michael hastings saying the fbi
has been investigating him
perhaps because he had already you know
they they knew they couldn't turn him
they couldn't convince him he wouldn't
work with them and he was going to
expose these big stories
to be fair i don't i'm not trying to you
know i know it may be it's a sore
subject for a lot of people
his family says that they essentially
discount these narratives these
conspiracy theories
the point is when you're an
investigative journalist
and you are staring down at the cia in
the fbi
powerful u.s massively funded interests
that don't want to have
bumps in the road they're not gonna let
you do it man yeah
now most journalists don't do any don't
do any reporting that really bothers
them like 99.9
but eventually you get someone who gets
leaked some real information and what
they got to do
they flee to hong kong or russia before
that information gets leaked to say
wikileaks or glenn greenwald
yeah and there's also the the big
information that
udo ufketi i'm saying it wrong he's the
german journalist that
worked for der spiegel that released and
and talked about how essentially
you know intelligence agencies were
writing entire articles that he just had
to put his name behind
and you know there's a large number of
these individuals that of course we need
to remind people of there are heroes out
there that do deserve to be commended
that do deserve to be talked about and
do deserve to be remembered
since of course you know having these
conversations is something that
is more imperative than ever especially
right now
so i have mixed feelings about the cia
like
in a way i value it because we have
i don't know secret spy agencies maybe
you you need them you know i don't know
it didn't exist before
1945. it's not all bad it's it's not
nothing's absolute
um i guess if you like living in america
and you like the interests that we have
in this country
like if you like the ability to go and
buy a pizza and live comfortably and
stuff
you have to you know recognize that
there are things being done
essentially in your name that you
probably would never agree with and
would not vote for
they do horrifying things yeah and the
justification is
you don't know about it and you get to
live comfortably and beautifully in the
united states
look they want to build the qatar turkey
pipeline a big reason for this big
conflict with russia and syria
is to get cheap gas into europe so that
people in europe can live better and
more cheaply
most people in europe would probably be
like i want cheaper gas and they do
there was rioting in france over
expensive gas
so intelligence agencies and
contractors real nasty people doing real
nasty stuff
are doing real nasty things so that you
can get your cheaper gas
and i try talking to a lot of activists
about this i'm like you have so many
people who love living in luxury
and that's why i think it's really
important that you you people get out
away from the big cities learn
to support themselves take
responsibility maybe chop some wood
learn how to hunt handle a firearm be
responsible for yourself
because if you want to sit here and
complain about warfare and
and and uh you know slavery and stuff in
countries like china with foxconn labs
you got to recognize that you are
reaping the benefits of war and slavery
and if you if you don't want to
acknowledge that then
fine that's on you for me i fully
understand that's what this world is
made of and what's going on
and i oppose it a lot of ways and i do
think we should get back to being more
self-sustainable
and soft reliant well yeah i would argue
about the the gas prices because it's
not
as simple as just gas prices i mean as
john perkins exposed with the economic
hit man
it's far more than that it's it's
interesting it's a lot of powers that
want more of it and they're going to get
their way one way or another
and it the only way they're able to is
because people stay silent is because
people are afraid it's because people
don't want to talk about these larger
issues but if we did it would expose
their game which is essentially rigged
which more and more people are finding
out
so i think it's more imperative to have
these honest real conversations and i'm
very happy to be a part of this one
because i think it's it's absolutely
needed this is why
nobody wants to be uh a real journalist
anymore
you look back in the day you had those
names woodward and bernstein now they're
kind of you know i guess
off the rails because you know was it is
it bernstein
who keeps saying everything's worse yeah
everything's worse than watergate it's
like okay
it used to be that if you were a
journalist and you exposed something you
were protected
because they were like we can't go after
this person because they're a famous and
respected journalist
that was a long time ago now they'll
just make up some insane story and call
you a nazi
and then your wife's premises you're a
russian boom done
there you go so if you're not going to
go down in history for doing a good
thing
if no one will like you and then you
will die by suicide with two gunshots to
the head
what incentive is there for anyone to
actually do investigations
none you're not gonna make money doing
it and everyone will hate you
because they will smear and they will
destroy you look before they they
so i was reading uh uh about well i
don't want to get too conspiratorial but
look at julian assange
how the media lied about julian assange
over and over and over again
just everything they put out about the
guy with smears and lies accusing me of
things he never did
they destroyed his character and then
they turned the left against him
amazing how it used to be the left that
loved wikileaks
now it's the left that hates wikileaks
it's amazing and donald trump loved
wikileaks too
and then he uh totally forgot who julian
assange was yeah that's yeah that's
really sad he was asked about it point
blank
i don't know who julian is i mean are
you kidding me so did you i love
wikileaks
i gotta ask you guys were you uh
disappointed by that or did you expect
it
that he wouldn't pardon him i don't know
i was i was a 50 50 i was like i wonder
i think he might
do it i i thought i knew he was not
going to do it and i was still very
disappointed that he didn't
so what what uh tipped you off what made
you think like there's no way he's going
to do this
well his his treatment of whistleblowers
has hasn't been that good
i mean his statements on chelsea manning
his statements on julian assange acting
like he didn't even know who he was
was a very telling sign as well as the
people around him i mean we heard
rumors that it was a lot of people
especially jared kushner
being one of the major people who was
against giving any kind of
freedom towards julian assange along
with other special interests that pushed
for this
and uh you know those voices were very
prominent and i think those voices
donald trump heard and listened to and
and sadly disappointed
a lot of his base that was expecting
this to happen yeah
he he had an opportunity for on the way
out to
just like really smack it to the machine
yeah but he wants to run again
yeah and so what we're seeing now really
yeah well with his impeachment so first
there's a video of him where he goes
we're trying really hard this is like
during it's like in december he's like
we're trying really hard
to to win to stay in but if we don't
we'll see in 2024.
so what's happening now is they're
impeaching him right he's filed his
rebuttal to the impeachment saying
i'm not an office you can't impeach me
the the constitution specifically says
that they can be impeached removed they
can be removed from
office or like impeachment serves the
purpose of removing them from office he
says well if i can't be removed from
office because i'm not in office you
can't impeach me right
so then he's arguing it says the purpose
of impeachment is to remove them from
office
and prevent them from holding office in
the future
trump says well as i can't be impeached
i can still run for office in the future
and you have no jurisdiction to
try a private citizen before he's in
public office before he's run or
whatever
or while he's not in office trump is
basically saying he wants to run
and the purpose of impeachment is to
stop him from being able to be president
again
drew holden said that jeff bezos wants
to run oh
he said he's running and i don't know if
that means running away from amazon
i wonder if you're watching amazon post
is going to win no zuckerberg bezos no
no no bezos
oprah bezos
i want to vote i want to vote for a
zuckerberg bezos ticket
you got it serious would you vote for
bezos
over kamala harris oh it doesn't have to
be commonly versed
i think it's going to be i think was
a republican it's not going to happen no
way no way he can't run oh that's tough
i mean i could never vote for come like
here's the thing i know i know i cannot
vote for kamala i'd have and i would not
want to vote for bazel i'd have to see
his policies i assume i just could not
vote for either but i don't know what
about zuckerberg
zuckerberg i don't know because he's
also they're both zuckerberg is also on
the left
zuckerberg for me like they're both
going to be pro-choice and i can't vote
pro-choice so what does that leave me
with
actually i don't know where bezos stands
on that but i'm pretty sure the next
republican that we get
who runs is going to be pro-choice oh my
goodness no joke
really hopefully super liberal just
remove any research if they don't take
down ted cruz ted cruz really looks like
he's going to be one of the
kind of favorites to be on the
republican ticket i don't know if ted
cruz
rubio i mean same with rand i think
those three are definitely the the
people that
really are going to be looked at in 2024
and donald trump's getting up there
as far as age and i don't think he's
going to do it i think i think if we
know anything about donald trump he's
all talk
yeah he's all bar exactly nobody exactly
and i think he's
doing that big sale yeah and i think he
keeps doing that i mean you read his
book
uh the art of the deal a lot of it is
just you know
pr to the max and and just
using information as a way to get as
much support as you can to get what you
can
and and that's essentially his
presidency so do you think they'll let
ted cruz run after he attempted to
murder aoc well well hold on she thinks
he actually was the zodiac let's be
clear
it's it's worse than that he didn't just
try he rallied all of his friends
and and i i remember this clear as day
i remember that video of ted cruz
holding the torch
leading the people down the hallway
screaming
this copy of green eggs and ham oh my
goodness
isn't he the zodiac no they're saying no
well
aoc thinks he was wasn't it his dad
though not him how did that come out
about it i think it was just a meme
right yeah yes
um trump didn't trump say something
about his dad being involved with like
jfk
he was clearly the zodiac killer it
settled
um luke i i am happy to hear that you
believe that uh you know cruz and rand
will
really be looked at i guess my question
is what are you basing that on why do
you feel they're the guys who are going
to because they're getting attacked the
most
so they're getting so you see the
targets i mean the establishment is
smart
i mean we're talking about the cia and
the information that they data harvest
especially from the nsa and all the
information that they know
i mean we're probably already with
predictive programming algorithms that
could predict the future i think we're
already there
and i think it's already being exploited
and i think the bigger kind of targets
that stand against them
they're already setting the the kind of
uh
the the the groundwork to kind of beat
them into oblivion and that's why we're
seeing such kind of
attacks on them that are kind of
ridiculous i don't i don't likes
i criticized all of them i have negative
things to say about all of them
but seeing the media landscape yeah yeah
seeing the media landscape against them
there's something that's up and i think
it's because they represent some of the
bigger ideas that a lot of mainline kind
of republicans and trump supporters also
kind of
in the middle ground resonate with what
if it's tucker tucker carlson for
president my goodness
i like him because he's the only one
that criticized donald trump effectively
he's the only one
not afraid sean hannity i mean he's a
total brown-noser
but but but tucker carlson like
literally called out trump on the issues
that actually mattered
people people noticed the budgets the
the the the coveted response everything
that that trump did bad
tucker was right on him so you gotta
give him credit it's incredible that
he's on television
well they're trying to take them down
too yeah exactly but that's why he's the
only one who saw ratings growth
yes when everyone else was doing better
yeah people don't know this about luke
but luke is uh you know he has a poster
of tucker
he's got
on things like marijuana i disagree with
him personally on issues like that
but i like hearing him because you know
he's going to come out with information
that that is going to be backed by some
kind of thinking
and i could agree with the thing and i
could disagree with the thinking but at
least i understand that
that it's coming from a perspective that
i could watch
and not understand that i'm being
tricked yeah exactly
i went into luke's rv and there was a
photo of me and luke and we were we were
on
the docks in coney island and he had his
arm around me he was giving his thumbs
up and he taped tucker crosston's face
over my face
late night in the basement of this house
you'll see luke watching tucker
i think tucker is the best per is the
best personality on tv right now 100
yeah he's the only and that's and i got
to be honest it's not saying a whole lot
because almost every single person on tv
is trash
exactly that's exactly it he's like the
only person who isn't just being handed
talking points
yeah there was some stuff a few years
ago where i watched like one thing about
marijuana legalization and it really
felt like he didn't agree with
he was this was years ago he was opposed
to it
and it really sounded like he didn't
really oppose it and was just trying to
make it seem like he did
yeah and i was like it's not working
tucker he's still against
decriminalization i remember a few years
ago when he was still wearing a bow tie
promoting war i confronted him
i confronted tucker carlson at the dnc
or
i was angry at him i was i was chasing
him down the hallways
now i'm like now i'm like you know this
is the thing
he's not trying to trick you yeah he's
like this is what i think this is the
information this is this is my
perspective take it or leave it
and i disagree with it sometimes but
it's a lot more genuine and
it's a lot more honest than all the
other bull crap on there because you
turn on sean hannity it's like
trump's the best he's i love him no
matter what and and and it's not clear
it's it's fogged with personal bull crap
when
you know do you see that that really
funny moment where tucker was
criticizing
how all these big corporations made
massive profits and stocks
were skyrocketing during the pandemic
and then when he was doing the handoff
with hannity
hannity was like he just jumps in and
goes if a company provides a service
they're going to make money and tucker
did the can like the
brow like oh you know look yeah that was
great
did did you grab him by the bow tie and
just keep twisting it you're like listen
here tucker
i don't touch people i have a big role
against that well it's funny because
i've i actually know people who have
worked with tucker who very much
disagree with him on everything but said
like he's one of their favorite people
he was confronted by joey boots i don't
know if you know remember joey boots
from occupy
he's no longer with us but he was a very
interesting was fishing
yeah tucker was fishing and the way
tucker responded to him was
was so nice and like still like it was
so genuine it was so real i mean if you
look up
look up joey boots and tucker carlson
and they just had an honest genuine
conversation when joey boots was being a
creeper
tucker was fishing in central park and
he was like can you fish here and he
goes you can
and he's like it's legal it is and then
he was like tucker is sat and like just
like all right
no no no no no no this is the thing joey
boots was filming him right and then
tucker knows he's like why are you
filming me
and then and i guess i guess joey didn't
know it was tucker carlson i don't know
if he did or didn't he said he didn't
know who it was then he was like you
know why are you filming me he's like
he's like can you fish here
like the establishment doesn't want you
to fish here yeah but tucker was like
does
do people get mad when you film he's
like yeah he's like oh he's like you
know all right
all right well how's it going he's like
you want to see what i caught and uh
what what he was like what are you
fishing he's like fly fishing and he
shows him and
he's a cool dude i was talking to
somebody i was in uh portland during
like uh some big
riot or something and somebody was
asking me
about who i liked and i said i like
tucker carlson and then some leftists
heard it and they started going like oh
oh
i started tweeting like overheard on the
street tim poole praising tucker carlson
and i'm like i will go on my youtube
channel and praise him if it makes it
easier for you
it's like it's not hiding that dude it's
because these people don't have
principles
so you look at some of these uh you know
personalities on cnn
and what do you get from cuomo giant
fake q-tip don lemon
it's not about principle it's about
tribal grifting emotional manipulation
most of all it's like look at the horror
look at the sadness look at this
pathetic
i mean it's it's milking things that
that again are is just
it's just petty it's poor it's pathetic
i want to blame rachel maddow
because i think she was the first and i
might be wrong about that but i feel
like she created a genre of
whoa i just got some light on my face i
think that's good though um
of that like emotional no no keith
olbermann kind of
yeah he went nuts dude what happened to
that guy there was a picture of him
underneath the flag
and someone tweeted keith it's safe to
go outside right now
it's okay trump's gone it's fine but he
absolutely lost it
uh we're having some lighter shot i
think i think it might be an electrical
issue
since the lights kind of went up and
we're dealing with some extreme weather
blizzard yeah i don't know if it's an
electrical issue but man is it crazy out
there yeah yeah
that one's right oh my gosh you know you
know what we can have a snowball fight
you know okay
no um but you know what's really crazy
just as a total side note
so i so you know most of you knows know
that we're out in the middle of nowhere
i was talking to the mail lady earlier
and uh she told me to make sure that we
have emergency food
i started laughing because we do the
promos and we were talking about the
other day and she was just like
you're in the middle of nowhere the
mountains get covered and you get
trapped and people don't realize it
like you need to make sure you're
stocked up and i started laughing i was
like thank you ma'am i appreciate it did
you tell her how much vinegar we have
no no but yeah whenever she knows didn't
it break in the how much vinegar did you
buy
25 gallons oh my gosh
so that we can live forever tim we're
not a vinegar what are you going to do
you know interesting we can boil grass
i made from scratch general so's chicken
you what it was good it was amazing from
scratch it was like a garlic i mean
sauce to uh to the extent you can like i
didn't make the soy sauce
but you know we mix vinegar and it's
interesting how you don't taste it when
you mix it into the sauce
yeah hey i got some info about covid i
wonder if you guys would like to hear
that
oh so this is just the new study that
came out and it was shocking to see and
facebook covered it up as potentially
fake news which i thought was weird but
it says who did the study do you know
who did that
stephen quay who's that is that
no he's a guy he's a medical doctor and
uh that's a phd
uh it says new study by stephen quake
concludes that sars cove what
came from a laboratory what's the story
what's the source what i've oh i'll look
it up
i actually sent this to you ap news ap
press yeah the associated press january
29th uh three days ago
and what when i read the story a little
bit check it out if you want new study
by dr stephen quay q uaw
um is that they were actually testing
the vaccines in 2019 in china
for the tsar's code i i i i can't i
can't
it's called new study by dr stephen quay
uh how do you spell quail q-u-a-w
concludes that sars cove two came from a
laboratory
i don't think i sent it to you on
facebook ap news.com
title new study dot by dr stephen coy
concludes that sars-cov-2 came from a
laboratory
q-u-a-w q-u-a-y oh okay
this is from it's it's no i'm sorry uh
ian this is a press release yeah paid
because
from pr news fake news uh yeah it's fake
are you 100
this is someone this is someone writing
a press release and then paying to have
it published on an ap press
press wire it's not it's not a report it
says on the top here press release
paid content from pr newswire
um so his 193 page paper is should we
dismiss it
yes and why is that because he paid to
have it promoted and until we actually
get hard publication of what the study
actually is we shouldn't be announcing
that it's true or anything like that
announcement is true
well well saying it's coming from the ap
when in fact it's coming from a paid pr
in a publicist okay so the ap will
promote paid work as well
the ap just shows a list of press
releases it doesn't mean any of it's
true
we'll see if the story gets picked up
it's not gonna get picked up and
i'll look into it the challenge is you
know look
just because the me doesn't cover it
doesn't mean it's fake news exactly but
i don't trust
because we've seen tons of stories like
this already they're not vetted
so just because a guy publishes and pays
for pr newswire doesn't mean it's
you know i'll put it this way i want to
fact check it before we mention it the
downside is
i cannot bring myself to read 193 pages
it's a long paper i'll put listen listen
i'll look into it
and i'll see if i can vet it in any
capacity learn about who this guy is
but you are bringing up a press release
with no vetting and no fact checking
yeah that's not we can't do that oh okay
because otherwise i'm not well yeah i
wouldn't try and prove it or anything
what were you gonna say
no i was gonna say let's go super chats
okay smash the like button ladies and
gentlemen if you haven't already make
sure you smash the like button you know
we do we are we're gonna we're gonna
have probably uh i think it's gonna turn
into a bonus episode on life after death
and religion
oh okay because we have this uh this
this story and i think it's gonna go too
long so we're gonna make it a bonus
segment
talking about netflix claims to have in
this documentary proof of life after
death excuse me and i think it is
well so they claim netflix did it well
well hold on
i could be wrong i want to make you
we'll save it for the segment and i
think it'll be a fun conversation and
it'll probably be long so it might end
up being this whole big spiritual
philosophical conversation
so go to timcast.com become a member it
should be up maybe around 11 or so as we
usually get these things up but because
it might run long it may be up later
later than that don't forget to smash
the like button subscribe hit that
notification bell and really
share the podcast if you like it because
that's how we grow let's read
your super chats i'm not your buddy guy
said the financial system is rigged the
media are propagandist
educators indoctrinate politicians or
tyrants the judicial system is corrupt
and voting is rigged what are we
defending is it worth preserving anymore
you know it's uh what is it empire's
last 250 years we talked about this a
couple weeks ago
maybe it's just that we don't have a
unified culture anymore
we don't have something where we're all
like we we believe in each other and
no it's just everyone out for themselves
the ship is sinking and everyone is just
trying to find a lifeboat to jump off
and swim away well here's the question
too
but the idea because i've heard this
that empires last about 250 years
is that from their inception as a
government or from the time when they
become an empire because we didn't
really become an empire until about 100
years
exactly but also social media could
accelerate the pace at which this kind
of social decay occurs
yep i think i think we're seeing
everyone say every man for himself
and that's why things kind of falling
apart yeah austin ghetto says glad
you're back sheamus it's been too long
oh i'm glad to be back too austin thank
you donnie 420 fy says do you have an
only fans and i'm going to assume that
he's talking to you seamus
no i don't have an only fans i have a
patreon patreon.comtune
and my patriot supply which tim also has
but i'm going to steal a spot by
patriotsupply.com
freedom tunes get some supplies sheamus
sheamus you can use only fans to like
show people how you draw and stuff isn't
that why isn't that usually used for
point i know but i
just don't even want to be a source
hold on when my channel was demonetized
i was like i'm just going to do my
regular videos but just put them on
there
what if what if what if jameis as you're
drawing your cartoons
you put your feet next no oh my god i
can't even talk about it no
no all right samantha says isn't it
strange the article says
aoc was in her office hiding but the
story she tells in a recent video
she's in a bathroom well yeah because
she said she was in the bathroom of her
office
and her staffers were out in the lot in
the office i guess to protect her
i don't know yeah i guess there you go
michael cobb says there are reports that
u.s special forces are in dc now what
are they
doing what are they doing slash about to
do that they need that kind of
protection
uh i haven't heard that i'll look into
that uh oh i don't know if i should read
this one ian they're mad at you
oh no should i read it yeah definitely
cat's claw says ian's a great example of
why drugs are bad they fried his brain
i've never heard a human say so many
stupid things in my life
that's a little harsh that was very
harsh
to people and i love you thanks sheamus
people either really love you or hate
you though you know i mean what's the
point
oh is it yeah a lot of people are like
cheering for you
i think i think what happens is when the
negative comments come in that's when
all the positive ones come in
that guy's defense i smoked weed for
like 16 years straight and it definitely
twisted my ability to memorize
information
and people don't realize that you don't
mean like periodically you mean
literally for 16 years you had a joint
in your mouth i was constantly being
replaced i smoked for like 600 days
straight away
but i used to memorize scripts you know
as an actor i met just my memorization
was off the chart and then
after i started smoking weed i started
thinking
more abstractly and so now i'm kind of
it's
changed the way my mind functions that's
for sure i'm sorry dent crow says great
i am a right-wing atheist like carl
benjamin why do you think so many
atheists go full left-wing slash tds i.e
bill maher sam harris and the entire
atheist community of austin texas
well many of the atheists became
anti-sjw
and yeah so and then we saw a bunch of
atheists just trying to fit in
but what a lot of people don't realize a
lot of the atheist community was fueled
by pro-lgbt rights it was social justice
so back in the day when the republicans
were anti-gay marriage
the atheist community had a large influx
of people who were pro-gay marriage
first
atheist second so when we you
you know moved to the natural conclusion
these are people who are interested in
social interested in social justice
not atheism the people who are atheist
first
are skeptics and critical of dogma
became anti-sjw
so i think a lot of people just assumed
the left was always
the you know the right place to be like
bill maher they call him alt-right like
he's really
not left at all he's actually more
moderate libertarian but he does have
trump arrangement syndrome you know i
was like and not now he is but 10 years
ago this is funny
when i um in 2013 when i was in my
my first college art course i remember
my teacher who i considered to be left
wing at the time
recommending joe rogan to me and i was
like oh there's probably some like hippy
left-wing nonsense can you imagine a
left-wing college professor
and by the way that college preparations
he's actually really cool i'm still in
touch with him but
just the fact that he was somebody who i
considered to be left-wing less than 10
years ago
they would expel you if you if you
mentioned joe rogan yeah you'd be like i
once watched joe rogan get out
get out now you nazi yeah that's that's
it
all right daniel maxwell says you know
the news media misses trump when the top
story of the day is aoc getting scared
by a cop trying to get her to a safe
location on january 6th
isn't that crazy like i'm here to save
you ma'am he's earning me he's yelling
at me
cody may says a preceding event to the
u.s civil war was senator preston
brooks beating senator charles sumner
nearly to death on the senate floor with
a cane
i i've heard that story be beating
jeez man let's see uh wmr photography
says i guess aoc never had any scare
scary moments on the short bus
sport which says if we only elected
veterans even desk jockeys get
get some combat training and remember
quote an armed society is a polite
society
manners are good when one may have may
have to back up his acts with his life
robert heinlein that's interesting this
is anecdotal and it could just be my
sample size
but uh the veterans i've met tend to be
very anti-war
oh yeah not i've i've had some messages
from people who are veterans who are
pro-war
definitely yeah no doubt oh i'm not i
mean is it dan crenshaw pro-war
yeah yeah he is yeah yeah yeah i'm not
saying it doesn't happen but many
and i think the anti-war veterans
they're like a special kind of anti-war
yeah they're they're i mean really
vehemently against it in a way that
other people aren't because they they
understand it more
all right we got amber kirilak she says
hey luke i had my vitamin d levels
tested and i was advised by my doctor i
need to take a daily supplement as i was
deficient
also i bought a hoodie from your store
can't wait to wear it well thank you so
much and
yeah i always recommend getting your
blood levels tested
and i'm not a medical doctor so don't
take any medical advice for me but
thank you so much and uh really
appreciate you
cliff sroka says hey guys love your work
even you ian
would love to have a conversation one
day over drinks and food hopefully not a
on a civil war battlefield well there
you go
cole frog is that pronouncing it right i
guess sheamus i liked your youtube
radicalization vid
it's just hypocritical how the left is
crying right-wing radicals
when there are left-wing youtubers
radicalizing viewers and calling for
violence
in a video game in a video in a video
game and minecraft in my car
thank you i very much appreciate that
cool i added the individual and i agree
yes they said in a video game
of course yeah ryan ball says the longer
i look at facebook and the mainstream
media
the more i feel like one of the dolphins
from hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy
silently observing the silly humans
unaware of their impending doom
so long and thanks for all the fish
that's a great it's a great
book slash movie right i love that yes
let's see angolian says back then being
dishonored
was a fate worse than death honor was as
important as life yes
now this would be called your rep but
people lie cheat and steal and get away
with it life goes on and people still
vote for them
yeah well because here's the thing it's
not as if they valued life less at that
point in history they just valued
themselves less yes now we all put
ourselves first
garhant says please please shamus do
gwen stefani's hollaback girl but
replace it with genseki doing circle
batgirl
i mean it's perfect for spoofing oh my
goodness that is hysterical i'm actually
really strongly considering that
circle here's the thing music videos are
much more difficult and expensive and
time consuming to make than the regular
cartoons
and that's not why i don't want to do it
the reason i don't want to do it is
because it
might take so long that by the time it's
done that wouldn't be relevant anymore
but i think that's really funny if
there's a way to pull it off i want to
figure it out
all right here's the best super chat
ever eric miller says pacifist tim poole
trying to be avatar aang uniting the
parties to fight the corruption
while not being on a side tulsi fighting
the corruption in her own party like
zuko
man that show was awesome yes uh do you
guys want to show that is
yes yeah that was a really great show
that's too it's too bad uh legend of
core was okay it's nowhere near as good
as as the the original but i like i like
legend of korea was fun
jeffrey perrine says biden does have a
low-key blurred halo in photos
i'll find some and send them to your
spin the ufo gmail i wrote last month i
can prove the bible i've been building a
case will also be emailed
interesting biden has a halo i've seen
those people well the media is
constantly telling me he's a devout
catholic despite the fact that he
doesn't no there's practicing so
they have the office of the president
over behind him and in his photos the
photographer lines it up so you see the
golden ring around
the light it's not a religion though no
no no no no
david merwin says tim you rock thank you
very much okay says tim please look into
these grifters
uh i don't wanna i'm not gonna name them
all the boomers that trump
that uh that all the boomers that
trump's still prez that think he is
oh yeah there are a lot of people
claiming that trump is still secretly
president
and i'm like we're all going to know
soon trump literally yeah
they keep pushing it off another couple
days dude give it more time than that be
like all right next year
after like the third time i said like in
a week i'd be like okay it's actually
going to be a year you guys
it's actually actually they're never
going to tell you just trust the plan
just believe me just go there you go
andrew land says hey seamus
thank you your conservatively
libertarian catholic world view
best view best reflects my own views you
in part helped renew my faith in october
i'm getting married and planning having
lots of catholic babies
that's how we will that's how we win the
culture god bless you that makes it all
worth it yep really
god bless you believe kaiser says i
agree ian the president doesn't matter
after all he is just a temporary
employee pretty sure a general said that
on ancient aliens or something
i mean it's true there's that we brought
this point up before though
that the the the presidency controls the
president for the most part
they get an office and they say here's
the here's the folder and they open it
and go
oh damn and then they're like i guess i
can only do what uh
you know we have to do trump on the
other hand was like no and he like
throws it out and he's like i'm
president i'm gonna do what i want and
they're like but look at this war and
he's like
no he did what he want and they didn't
like it
jim jam says what are your thoughts
about this news about the national guard
that are still being sent to dc to root
out racism white supremacy and
disinformation
i didn't hear that is that true i didn't
hear that either yeah i don't know
not cool i will look into it sword and
scale says tim did you see
the desantis press conference today and
do you think anything will come out of
florida's war against silicon valley
oligarchs
i didn't see it i heard a little bit
about it but i'm not confident anything
will happen because there was actually i
think it was in texas
they maybe not texas but there were some
states that filed at the state level
to make censorship like social media
ship not allowed and they didn't go
anywhere
but uh shout out to sword and scale it's
like one of the biggest podcasts in the
world isn't it
so it's like a crime uh podcast yeah
thanks to the super chat
xavier says i am a gorilla thank you for
all you guys do been watching you for at
least five years now
would love if you could shout out my
band's new single sleeping
by kaskara it's progressive metal well
there you go
sleeping by c-a-s-c-a-r-a i hope i
pronounced it right
and uh let me see if the you know what
let me make sure i get the i am a
gorilla
right there t-shirt if you guys want
your exclusive
i am a gorilla t-shirt you can go to
timcast.com click shop and boom there it
is
and a lot of people got the misprinted
one where his hands were white and his
face was darkened
uh-huh i did but they fixed it so thank
you t-spring for fixing the problem
all right let's let's move on mr roach
says hell oh it just jumped on me thanks
youtube i love it when they do that
youtube has this thing where it doesn't
load all at once and then it loads and
then i got to spend 20 minutes trying to
figure out where it went
mr roach says hello beanie lord and the
and the parking lot rebel
i listen to you every day and decided to
get my very own subscription to your
site
i'm a regular guy from ohio and play in
a band called someday saturday
what is your advice on creating good
culture being in a band
yeah writing music and putting it on
social media and
it's the best of your abilities lead by
example and don't let feel
fear rule your life and i like that
parking lot rabble
i'm taking that stealing that thank you
there you go ryan says luke tim serious
question
ever a story in which government
justified in using underhanded tactics
any justified covert ops thanks for all
you do god bless
i mean wasn't like writing about bin
laden covert
well it depends what which version of
the story you want to believe since the
government came out with many different
versions of them
the one where he used his wife as a
human shield oh yeah and they were like
oh actually that didn't happen
exactly or there's so many like
misnomers about that story so i don't
know what to make of it
uh but um i'm gonna have to do some
research on that because um
again when everything's done in darkness
there's a lot of potential for it being
done wrong
so that's the biggest issue that i think
still needs to be addressed
eric miller says third super chat i was
wondering if anyone
ever thought about creating a video
stockpile website for news a journalist
can post a video on it and charge small
fee and an independent channel can buy
it it's called uh
it was originally called corbis now
gallop does this but it's been around
for like 100 years
well not that long but uh i i no no did
i say gallop i mean getty not yeah
yeah yeah getty so getty takes photos
and videos and i think they recently
they bought corbis
and i'm pretty sure they also do video
and a lot of journalists do this
they upload their videos and photos and
then people pay like 25 to 50 bucks to
buy the rights to it
here's a crazy thing some people's whole
job is they just travel the world and
they film
scenic places they'll put a camera up on
by like a lake and a mountain and just
film for like three hours
and then they'll put the footage on a
website and say this footage is
available for you know 25 bucks per
license
and they make tens of thousands of
dollars off the one video because movies
and documentaries and commercials want
to use a small portion of it it's crazy
there was one i saw where someone filmed
like fireworks in japan
ended up making a million bucks that's
all they did they brought a really nice
camera out got cinematic quality
put it up and said 25 bucks per use and
it was just fireworks but it was so
generic and easy to use
they made like a million plus dollars i
was talking to one of these executives
who runs one of these companies who told
me about it
and there was one person who randomly
stumbled upon
uh stephen tyler took a photo of him and
it was like the only photo of him at a
certain
point or something and they put it on a
site and it sold for like millions of
dollars so that stuff exists
there you go yeah i mean some movie con
uh you know movie companies contacted me
and uh my stuff was even in some movies
you know wild you know i sold i i sold
to uh what channel was it it may have
been national geographic i'm not sure
this was during hurricane hurricane
sandy in new york i was out filming the
flooding and everything and then they
they some company bought a license to
the footage but that's because i saw it
on youtube
thumb ugly says eighth attempt because
youtube learn a trade
stock up and lids for ambivalent
dictator
i give up on original comment attempts
i'll join your site there's a comment
section
so if you want to comment a lot of
people you know if you go to the members
area you'll just see the content
but if you actually click the title or
on the front page click it you'll see
the comment section and that you can
comment on if you're a member
and so then people can have these
conversations christian b says tim
sucks freedom tombs is the best jk love
you guys
i don't know freedom tunes is pretty
good i don't know what he was joking
about
i love you thank you tim rocks liam
mason says can you give a british shout
out to captain
sir tom moore who sadly passed today at
100 years old
he raised 32 million for the nhs last
year and inspired a nation in these dark
times keep up the great work
world war ii vet yeah brendan sweeney
says do you think tim dillon would make
a good president tim dillon 2024
i like that idea i've met him before uh
he's a funny guy
zombie tanker 19k says dan crenshaw
2024.
[Music]
[Laughter]
you know he gets ragged on a lot by a
lot of people and i don't agree with him
a lot of things but i do
i do think he's all right i disagree
with him a lot i respect the red flag
laws
the pro-war stuff you know those are
pretty big issues
those are serious issues but i don't
think he's a bad guy i think he
genuinely believes it and i think he'll
engage in an honest way and you'll be
like dude that's i really disagree with
you
but you look at some of these
politicians and they don't even like
when the ones that are pro-war aren't
even really pro-war
they're just like do i get paid sure
stamp
pardon will says how much to put my
application and cv into tim cast llc
um there is no such thing um and
i don't know well it doesn't cost money
to do it but people email that stuff all
the time
and man it's really hard because i
mentioned this before
uh we we had a really difficult time
with
all of the membership signups we got for
timcast.com and the site is only a few
weeks old
we're redoing the format we're expanding
the amount of content we produce
we're probably going to be making
multiple websites hiring a hundred
people doing more shows and expanding
and becoming an actual large network and
the only thing stopping us is
time thanks to all the people who have
signed up we're now in a position where
we can actually start growing and
expanding in a very powerful way
so go to teamcastle.com become a member
but we're definitely gonna be hiring as
well
gun star one says would you have jimmy
dore on your show any time
the issue is traveling dudes in
california but uh jimmy's awesome
and uh i told the story before we're
from the exact
same place no joke like huh same street
so he's way older than i am
but we when i was like a little kid and
he was
in his 20s i think i don't know we lived
within like two or three blocks of each
other
it was crazy when i when i first
actually met him in person you know i
was like i'm from chicago and he's like
oh no kidding me too where at now i was
like midway era and he goes get out of
here we're at and i was like by vietnam
park and he goes
i lived right next to it and i was like
get out of here dude that's crazy
that's hilarious that's where we live
okay where are you then i'm midway right
yeah we were there we were just sitting
there watching the whole thing we're
like
my goodness what's going on here we saw
alex jones because we were hanging out
i forgot who we were hanging out we were
hanging out with another yeah we were at
the rnc but we were hanging out with
another news group
and we saw alex jones walk by i was like
oh man he's going to do something
and the young turks were filming he
certainly did stephen colbert had a
roomba with a live camera there and uh
yeah then there was a lot of fireworks
huh sword and scale says i just paid ap
to publish a press release about tim
poole announcing she's trans
please announce this since i paid for it
that's crazy i'm very proud of you
so she i organizations
and but they are willing to just take
money from anybody and post
that's what the media does that's the
mainstream media
that's the definition of them it's like
ap news uh
of course but they'll post junk but they
straight up said this is a paid press
release
do or do news organizations do that on
the regular yeah yes
how can you pick how could you be like a
do you know what an identifiable news
organization just got ready for you guys
advertorial it's a brilliant right it's
where news organizations
write favorable articles for companies
and make it look like a regular news
article
advertorial like editorial and
advertisement combined
so you'll go to a website and i think
buzzfeed is all the time
it'll be like these are the best dish
sets you'll ever use and you'll read it
and then at the bottom and find princess
this is an advertisement paid for
and it looks like a normal article so i
could be like hey here's an article that
says timple stinks
i pay a bunch of money would they post
that yes but it says at the top this is
a paid post by this organization and bbc
news
did a whole segment literally promoting
tequila it was disgusting the way they
were doing it it looked like a total
news segment it was on twitter
but it was like yeah it was so
refreshing and good just
like i get you know you know i get a lot
i get people saying
would you interview my company and i say
i think your company is interesting but
no then they say
can we pay you to do an interview with
the ceo of this company to help promote
his product and i'm like
no like that's not interesting to
anybody
and i would rather just sleep all day
than take money to just interview a guy
so he can promote his company
you know i mean i won't do it we we have
people on who promote their companies
like sheamus go to freedom tunes
youtube.com freedom tunes you guys
but it's because jamis produces
culturally relevant content and he has a
channel
and so we definitely have people on who
promote their stuff promote their books
but there are companies that aren't
culturally culturally relevant they'll
like
you know we make uh um you know rulers
that are the best rulers for drawing
pictures can we come on your show and
we'll pay you and i'm like no
like dude if you want to do a sponsor
spot we can talk about a sponsor spot i
can promote rulers if i think the
ruler's actually good
but some people actually want to have
the show and i'm like that's
a lot of companies do it a lot of
companies do it you people don't realize
this
you might see an interview on tv and
it's a guy talking about a very
important product or something
and and and they're paying the company
to have him on the show cnn does stuff
like this all the time where
they actually run shows that are paid
for by governments by companies like
they did one called bahrain business
friendly and it was heavily criticized
glenn green was criticizing it
where basically bahrain paid to publish
favorable
coverage of bahrain as kind of a news
segment that promoted the country's
tourism
meanwhile there was like riots going on
and people it was during the arab spring
so they were heavily critical criticized
for it there you go that's what media
does they'll be like something something
something fake news by the way it's paid
advertisement yeah
they do it well it's like i'm saying i'm
gonna murder that person this is the
thing a video game like if they do it
yeah and it i mean
and they say it i mean there's an
argument to be made there but a lot of
these people do it and
they don't even say what if i was like i
don't believe this but and then gave you
like violent instructions to go kill
people
there there was uh you have to see
everything but i said i didn't believe
it you ever see the show
that's like the widest guys you know i
think it's called the white house
yes this is i remember this he's like
don't do this this is a way you could
he explains how to attack the white
house yes and then he's very it's
it was hilarious and i can't believe
they did it he's like you could tell my
lawyers have informed me that i can't
tell you to go to the white house and
look at and and and go in this direction
and
now i can't tell you to then i was like
that's crazy yeah dude it is crazy all
right let's see
uh ryan cronin says ian for president jk
that would be nuts but ian's okay
would be to your first directive would
be your first yeah
joe biden has 43 executive orders what
would be your first two weeks what's
your first executive order as president
ian
uh well i don't know how much power i
would have but i would like to you could
sign into law whatever you want an
executive order i would like to audit
the federal reserve
i love it send in the fbi to storm the
building you know what mine would be
it would be that from now on cilantro
fennel
anise caraway uh yes
those and coriander i guess but that's
basically same thing in cilantro those
are now schedule one
i back this completely uh oh 100 yep
all of those gone oh yeah yeah i'm gonna
make you a fennel coriander
cilantro he'd love that
david phillips says are you afraid to
talk about election fraud due to your
channel being shut down
no uh because we talk about it a lot
we've talked about it a whole lot i've
done like a month's worth of content on
it
i don't know what else to say i don't
know but it's just we're at this point
where it's like what do we do what are
we talking about
uh media matters tried smearing us that
was really funny that was funny what did
media matters say
do you remember when media matters so
jack murphy is on the show yeah and he
said
donald trump gave concrete examples of
voter fraud
think you know matt brennan stuff like
you know that's what that was his
comment
media matters claimed that we were
pushing the the theories
simply because jack murphy said donald
trump said isn't that insane what
donald trump said a thing ah you pushed
it no we didn't we referenced trump said
it you did the same thing when you
referenced we said it
are you pushing it and the best part was
they claimed that our videos were
demonetized
never happened they were like all of
these videos so they met they referenced
five videos
four of them got removed because they
were like very serious claims about
fraud and ours was like donald trump
said a thing and they tried smearing us
so youtube was like what what what is it
like this is fine like they didn't do
anything
so media matters like four of the five
videos were removed all had their ads
removed our ads weren't removed
don't tell them that don't tell them
that they're going to like i demanded
them
no i emailed them and demanded a
retraction and they didn't do it
and then and then i followed up saying
i'd like a retraction and they still
didn't do it
because what happens now is another
article come out and being like tim
poole whose videos have been
you know stricken down by youtube in the
past for rule violations
that's what they do it just means
they're making interesting content
that's right it's just
but it was not true our ads were not
removed
uh the the on any video ever we've had
yeah exactly
but they're they were saying that we got
in trouble with youtube or something
yeah
youtube youtube did not punish honest
and in any way the video is fully
monetized the podcast is fully monetized
we didn't have any issues
it's got it's got a quarter of a million
views all
that happened was jack murphy was like
donald trump said this and they were
like
they got to be careful so disappointed
with jack with jack murphy the other
illinois boys if you go around and say
like a company's losing
money and they're not that's dangerous
that's like liable or
something it's yeah i think that's
interesting i don't know if it's liable
but that is like that is a concrete
thing to reference i mean
that is easily provable or disprovable
yeah that's not just a matter of opinion
what they said is literally not true the
the podcast never had it's it's taken
away
yeah and so i emailed them like yo
what's up with this
and i yeah i think if you state that a
company is losing revenue that's like a
that's like a crime well they said
youtube has removed ads from the videos
we named it indicating that the
company's losing revenue
maybe there's some kind of like semantic
argument but they ignored it anyway i
don't care whatever
like you know they they for no reason
they included our show
in the smear and the other videos did
get removed because they were saying
very bold claims and making hard
assertions that we don't make even when
we had matt brennan on the show matt
brainer didn't make any definitive
statements
he talked about what he's seen what his
evidence is and what he would like to
see
you know in court and we there you go i
agree these other channels are like
making definitive statements and they
got taken down
why include us in that i even emailed
being like none of what you've accused
of these other channels pertains to us
in any way
we actually agree with what you said in
terms of you know like
voter fraud exists it's not bill barr
said this and we haven't had
adjudication i'm like what's the problem
they just they just want to go after
everybody and whatever i
don't i don't care to talk about it you
know whatever demolisher says
hi to sheamus name to my sons jameis
don't hear it
every day best name ever god bless you
good i'm glad it's a good name
um i my condolences your children though
it's a rough one it's a rough one to
have to wear every day
people mispronounce it all the time i
consider that to be a microaggression
indeed i read an article about how it is
it is a
a mark of privilege and not have your
name mispronounced so i was like at
least i got one
i know we still have one impression of
coughlin the worst i ever got was
seamstress couplings
at a video festival in high school i i
had a friend named
sean i had a friend named sean in grade
school and one substitute teacher called
him scene
yeah and i was just like he's not here
to be seen yeah but it's like a little
kid i'm like
did you not know that's how you say sean
yeah i'm a little kid and i knew that
yeah like uh whatever yeah
all right here we go uh vosh says no
anna's no peace
no delicious honey says thanks tim for
an awesome show it's always entertaining
and informative thank you
heather coran says coriander is cilantro
fy i also please know i will lose my
mind i need
salsa guacamole etc you know what you
know the best guacamole
is we used to get this made all the time
you go to these places they make the
guacamole in front of you no cilantro
extra lemon lemon juice lemon juice lime
juice yeah
extra lime juice extra onion no cilantro
i think you're missing out on the
cilantro
no i think it's disgusting it's amazing
so coriander is the plant that the
cilantro beef grows on right right right
yeah yeah it's like the stem parts and
then coriander that's basically the same
thing there is actually a gene that
makes some people
think that cilantro tastes like soap i
do not excuse me
yeah it doesn't taste good it's medicine
but you got to like trick your body into
starting to crave it i don't think
cilantro tastes like soap i've never
understood it i think cilantro is
overpowering and it tastes
bad i don't like it yeah it's like
medicine i don't know people like it
so good for you dan murphy says you just
lost support your spice supremacy sucks
bait like basil is pretty good okay
these are great
garlic on everything top once you're
like is it one of your top
garlic yeah i will put garlic on a
pancake
i've seen him do it he has he wants to
keep the vampires away yeah he's making
all these day walkers raw garlic yeah
it's intense
no but you know what i love doing is
when you make a pizza you put whole
cloves on it oh yeah and bake it
and then they become soft and they just
oh garlic garlic's best yeah you can
roast garlic you take a full clove of
garlic you slice off the top part and
then you just put it on
pans and then when it comes out you
squeeze them out of their their shell
basically and you have this soft
garlic uh actually you know what
mandatory garlic yes
second executive order everybody gets
garlic they come to your house you have
to fight the vampires ending the
pandemic
garlic garlic for everyone garlic just
there you go yep and it's good it's good
for you
skyrim 96 says you guys should have your
should have up church on your show he's
like tom mcdonald but he's at the
forefront of country rap and will go
down
in music history interesting interesting
all right let's see we'll just do a
couple more here william j says having
luke aka uncle eddie on the show as a
regular always brings the show to a
higher level
great job tim poole team don't say that
you're making it make his head big
um he demanded thank you very much he
demanded a bowl of of only green m m's
[Laughter]
at least at least i'll get to eat dude
looks like you said the last time i had
i was here some of them had w's on them
i'll tell you an interesting story i'll
tell you an interesting story
so that whole idea that rock stars
demand
crazy things because they're egotistical
is a myth
it started because i can't remember the
name of the band but you guys probably
listening you might know this
this band uh a very famous one i can't
remember which one
had in their contract for their for
their you know
tour right somewhere in the bay in the
middle was that a bowl
of m m's with no bread with all the
brown eminem's removed will be made
available for the band
and a lot of people in the media saw
that and thought it was that this band
is egotistical and demanding and makes
no sense
the reality was apparently the band had
been playing on stage and the stage
collapsed and they were like people got
injured
and so the idea was put something in the
contract that's
seemingly nonsensical because if they
don't do it it means they didn't read
your contract oh wow that is fascinating
if they show up and saw the m
ms weren't there it wasn't that they
wanted m ms it was that if they skimped
on something as dumb as picking out m
ms what did they also skimp out on
supports for the stage
supports for the audience lights fire
extinguishers
they're in um partly to explain why they
have these weird riders sometimes is
because when you're a performer your
body is a tool you're using your body
like a tool to have a very specific
task like making a sound that's very
challenging for the human body to make
and if it isn't in the right you know
mindset or or physical place it's
hard to make that sound and then the
production suffers so you might want
like no aspartame no you know i want
just just
salmon on my and uh thanks for the shout
out we'll see what happens
uh alternative jk says after noticing
both you and luke have a habit of
mispronouncing things you should make a
shirt that says potato
po pot tat toe you get the idea
potato puppy open to help design the
shirt as well well i'm really bad with
pronouncing names i love it
that's about it i just screamed through
them no luke doesn't mispronounce words
luke accidentally chooses similar
sounding words yeah it happens like
fraudulent slip instead of freudian slim
okay
luke's defense english is not his first
language yeah yeah yeah yeah thank you
lydia
and also luke's bringing the fire and
plenty others yeah i mean yeah
give him a break yeah jan stankiewicz
says luke do you ship your shirts
internationally by the way i believe
luke is lucas in polish pronounced
wukash
freedom tunes is my fave guest on tim
castro that's the thing is
in the polish bible uh and uh some of
the stuff
is shippable internationally but a lot
of the stuff is getting banned i never
wanted to have limited supplies of
shirts but but they're forcing me to do
so because they're taking so many of
them down
some of them do ship internationally
some of them don't you have to go on
uh the best uh the
bestpoliticalshirts.com to find out
ladies and gentlemen go to timcast.com
shop click shop and you can see the i am
a gorilla t-shirt
some have asked about the i am a gorilla
love yourself shirt we are working on
this we also have a shirt for for ian
coming soon oh i saw
i saw it it'll be fun and we're working
on one for for luke about
you know mispronouncing words we might
have to get some copyright in there
get some contract all right we'll figure
it out or we just won't do it
you know whatever but uh go to pbs.com
become a member because we are gonna
after this wraps up we're gonna record a
bonus
episode for all of you members about
life after death
and religion and philosophy and have
probably a very interesting and
fun conversation that uh i guess
wouldn't fit because we've probably gone
for a really long time so go to
teamgas.com become a member we're gonna
record right after this
which is very soon come back tomorrow
night live at 8pm well we will be here
and we'll be doing the show once again
you can follow me on twitter instagram
and mines at tim cast
my other youtube channels are
youtube.comtimcast youtube.comcastnews
if you're listening on the podcast like
itunes or spotify leaves a good review
share the share the podcast help us grow
and shamus
you also produce things that people can
watch yes i make cartoons uh so if you
want to check out youtube.com
freedomtunes and watch those they're a
lot of fun to make we make
at least one a week sometimes two a week
and we've been expanding and growing and
that's fantastic but
because we have to crank out these
shorter videos sometimes even when they
are monetized we don't pull a whole lot
of money out of them so if you want to
help us create more and you like them
you can also check out patreon.com
freedom tunes i am the parking lot
rabble and also an independent
journalist and if you want to be
involved with what i do
you can on we are change.org forward
slash donate today i'm also wearing
another we are change exclusive t-shirts
that is a pie chart and is censored with
green tape
and it says uh in a family-friendly way
ish you know which is represented here
ish you know you don't know and then in
the bottom here
ish you don't know you don't know which
is the larger pie
representation it's the universe it's
amazing exactly so if you want one of
those you can on
thebestpoliticoshirts.com thank you
again so much for uh supporting me
and you can follow all of my paid
advertisements on the ap
yes indeed i'm just kidding about that i
would not do that hey you can follow me
on the internet at eddie and cross on
twitter youtube
and instagram actually you can uh follow
me on twitter because i go live
during the day somewhere between one and
three o'clock on twitch and where i do a
game streaming session and hang out with
everybody and
chat it up well i'm going to be locking
in an exact time it'll probably be
around 2 p.m but this week it's going to
be
there about so follow me on twitter and
i'll let you know when i go live very
cool
and i am sour patch lids on twitter and
minds and real sour pastulates on
instagram and
gab you can follow me there we'll be
back tomorrow at 8 pm live but we're
gonna have this bonus
episode coming up at timcast.com so go
there sign up check it out and we will
see you all then
bye guys
you